[Musique]
Jean-Luc Mélenchon bonsoir bonsoir nous
vous recevons pour une chaîne internet
qui s'appelle Serview nous sommes en
direct est-ce que vous pouvez vous
présenter
succintement alors je m'appelle Jean-Luc
Mélenchon je suis né le 19 août 1951 à
Tanger au Royaume du Maroc ce qui veut
dire que j'ai en ce moment 72 ans euh
j'ai été sénateur conseiller général
sénateur député européens puis député
national et maintenant je suis en
retrait mais pas en retraite on a décidé
de vous faire venir ce soir pour parler
de fond parler de géopolitique parler
peut-être de finances d'économie parler
de sujet est vraiment ou qui vont
toucher les jeunes générations on
parlera un peu de votre bouquin même
certainement au j'ai le droit de le
montrer là voilà faites mieux c'est
première question c'est un testament ah
non je sais pas ce qu'il y a en ce
moment parce que j'ai une tête de mort
mais l'autre jour on m'a fait pareil
dans une émission à la fin on me dit
qu'est-ce que vous pensez vous avez peur
de la mort c'est pas un testament au
sens oui et non allez pour pour
être ça veut dire c'est une vie sur une
période historique dont je ne verrai pas
le bout le dire ce n'est pas être
désespéré c'est juste être réaliste
contenu de l'âge que je viens de de vous
rappeler il est certain que si vous ne
changez rien et que vous laissez les
choses aller comme elles sont bon à la
fin du siècle la boutique sera fermée
bon moi la fin du siècle c'est quand
même dans un moment donc je n'y serai
pas vraisemblablement mais je n'exclus
pas d'y être encore qui sait qui sait
parce que je reste quand même un
optimiste sur la science sur la capacité
des êtres humains à surmonter les
épreuves les difficultés peut-être parce
que j'ai beaucoup lu de de
science-fiction alors alors ça
donne ça donne à la fois de la confiance
dans l'imagination humaine parce que je
sais que vous aussi vous lisez de la
science-fiction et franchement ce qui
continuera toujours à nous scotcher
c'est la capacité qu'on eu des gars à
raconter ce que nous sommes en train de
vivre et pour ce qui me concerne il y a
même des épisodes que j'ai vécu
personnellement comme l'holologogramme
euh dont j'ai emprunté l'idée à une un
roman de science-fiction d'Isaac Azimov
qui s'appelle fondation fondation et
empire la seconde
fondation qui était un roman euh à
l'époque j'étaai pas vu alors j'avais
j'étais marxiste déjà je pensais qu'
avec ça j'avais la clé qui ouvrait
toutes les portes et puis je tombe sur
ce roman de science-fiction il l'auteur
parle de la psychoistoire donc la
psychoistoire c'est compenu de la
psychologie de chacun comment ça
s'organise et quel résultat ça va donner
alors là pour moi c'était grandiose
parce que j'avais un rapport un peu
critique à l'idéal euh à la la
description marxiste et je trouvais que
le comment dire la partie culturelle
existait mais que elle elle ne jouait
pas un rôle et moi j'ai toujours pensé
que les êtres humains ça c'est un propos
d'aujourd'hui accèdent au réel par un
filtre qui est leur pensée et on pouvez
pas dire bah oui c'est un filtre non non
c'est alors qu'est-ce qu'il y a dedans
comment ça marche comment ça s'accumule
et alors j'en profite hein parce que
j'abuse de la situation donc vers euh tu
vois 13 14 ans j'étais pas un gamin
comme toutous les autres un peu bizarre
et donc je découvre à la fois une
histoire de la Révolution française qui
va fixer mes convictions politiques et
puis je tombe sur un auteur c'est un
curé un jésuite qui s'appelle Tillard de
Chardin et theyard de Chardin parle de
quelque chose qui à l'époque un truc
purement mystique il dit voilà tous les
êtres humains pensent tous les êtres
humains échangent des pensées et cette
ce filtre là entre eux et le réel ça
porte un nom ça s'appelle la noosphère
noosphère c'est Noos pour l'esprit la
sphère sphère de l'esprit alors bon lui
pour lui c'est c'est un mystique hein
donc il croit en Dieu il voit la
perspective de l'histoire et il dit que
la noosphère se dirige tu vois petit à
petit elle elle se condense et à la fin
elle arrive à l'idée pleine et entière
de Dieu je vous le raconte pas en détail
parce que je suis pas le mieux placé
pour vous raconter un truc pareil mais
moi ça m'avait impressionné cette idée
du mouvement des êtres humains pensant
et leur pensées se joignant et euh
pendant que j'écrivais le livre j'étais
sur cette idée de la culture cumulative
et ça ça bon comment ça marche et tout
puis elle est toute numérisée
aujourd'hui et il y a une interface qui
s'appelle on met des grosse guillemets
l'intelligence artificielle qui brasse
tout ça vous avez un énorme stock de
données tous les jours un peu plus grand
et puis il y a une machine qui s'est
chercher en quelques secondes au bon
endroit et assemblé et je me dis mais ce
truc paf ça me revient je me dis mais
c'est la neosphère ah la neosphère faut
absolument que je mette ça dans le livre
je le mets tu es un peu embarrassé quand
même un gars comme moi qui se met à
citer un
jésuite pour être franc je sais que ce
gésuite a été réhabilité par l'actuel
pape qui lui-même est un gésuite
et je me dis bon je vais quand même
chercher parce que peut-être que c'est
pas lui qui avait trouvé le Monot
noosphère je cherche et je trouve ouf je
suis sauvé un savant chimiste
soviétique qui lui a découvert le
concept de biosphère qu'on utilise
aujourd'hui à partir d'une idée qui si
on me l'avait dit plutôt j'aurais
compris plus vite ce que ça voulait dire
biosphère lui dit tout organisme vivant
et vivant parce qu'il est dans un
échange chimique avec son environnement
et tous nous transformons de l'oxygène
en CO2 et les plantes transformment du
CO2 en oxygène donc nous sommes tous
nécessairement dans la même bulle waouh
alors il trouve ça et puis il trouve
l'idée de noosphère alors c'est vers les
années 30 donc à ce moment-là c'est une
vue de l'esprit et pendant que je suis
en train de bosser ça je me dis mais si
il y a quand même une nouveauté je vous
rappelle je suis un amateur de
sciencefiction il y a une nouveauté
terrible c'est pas que le savoir humain
qui est mis dans la sphère numérique
bien sûr tout il scan tout il mett tout
mais maintenant jusque là la culture
culative c'est de la culture d'être
humain vous moi ce qu'on a écrit ce
qu'on a calculé ce qu'on a pensé ce
qu'on a fait ce qu'on a vu les photos
allez en avant mais là il y a une
nouveauté unique nouvelle
stupéfiante la culture cumulative la
noosphère comporte le savoir des objets
les objets connectés envoie des millions
d'informations qui sont dans les bases
et métadonnées et qui rentre dans la
culture collective des êtres humains or
ni vous ni moi nous ne savons utiliser
ce savoir moi je sauraai quoi faire d'un
verre je sauraai quoi faire d'une photo
je sauraai quoi faire d'un mot d'un
verbe mais qu'est-ce que je peux faire
dans ma tête du nombre de pas que vous
faites tous les jours ou du nombre de
vos battements de cœur qu'est-ce que ça
m'apprend j'en sais rien mais ça apprend
aux assureurs la mince magna elle le
sait je dis la mince magna parce que il
y a
de science-fiction qui s'appelle le
lendemain de la machine où il y a une
mince magna c'est un mec a déclenché une
catastrophe mondial et quand il sort de
par hasard de l'opération dans laquelle
il était chaque fois qu'il croise
quelqu'un les gens pour le saluer disent
bonjour maudit soit Mantler auson le
manler aon c'est lui alors il dit rien
quoi il va puis il découvre que ce
Mantler aon a pris la mauvaise décision
c'est-à-dire un tir nucléaire et il va
il s'aperçoit que les gens s'arrêtent à
cabine téléphonique pour téléphoner je
dis à qui il téléphone tous ces gens il
y va il décroche et quand il décroche il
y a quelqu'un qui lui dit bonjour c'est
la mince magna de quoi avez-vous besoin
donc si vous voulez c'est chat GPT
chacun d'entre nous la croise dans la
rue en quelque sorte je dis chat JPT
parce que c'est ce que tout le monde
connaît mais il y en a un autre qui est
français alors donc tirait il y aurait
des cabines et il y aura un problème
genre ah combien il faut mettre de pincé
de de sucre dans le gâteau je vais faire
tout à l' pour le gamin alors pour
faireter le gâteau tu ferais quoi M
magna alors elle répondrait c'est chat
GPT alors ça pourrait être n'importe
quoi tout d'un coup je me demande tu
peux me rappeler le nom de ce cette
équation qui dit comment les chiffres du
début sont transformés par la conclusion
de la fin tu peux me le dire me
l'expliquer bref voilà comment en
écrivant le livre j'ai patogé dans le
21e siècle et pour être franc bien sûr
mon livre il est terrible il vous dit si
vous faites rien si vous faites pas
mieux que ce qu'on a fait vous êtes tous
morts le capitalisme à 1 milliard c'est
immoral à 8 milliards c'est suicidaire
et à 10 milliards c'est mortel or vous
allez être 10 milliards si vous faites
rien si vous avez pas trouvé une idée
pour changer ce Tru c'est foutu mais
donc c'est assz terrible comme
diagnosticque mais quand même je peux
pas m'en empêcher peut-être parce que je
suis un homme d'un autre temps d'être
plein d'enthousiasme tu vois ça me
fascine j'aimerais tellement voir la
suite l'action et sort du rêve c'est ça
tu connais le poème de Saint-Pierre
roncement de Saint-Pierre
écoute j'ai évolué dans la vie parce que
le pour rester sur ce registre quand
j'étais petit à petit en murissant bon
plus jeune je m'en foutais en réalité
j'avais été croyant je ne l'étais plus
bon c'était pas le sujet il y avait
autre chose à faire on allait faire la
révolution socialiste bon très bien et à
partir de là tout changé c'est pas ce
qui s'est passé du tout alors bon il y a
eu toute sorte de gens qui sont tombés à
genoux et certains au sens littéral
c'està-dire sont devenus des adorateurs
du système et qui sont devenus aussi
férocement libéraux et sectairement
libéraux qu'ils étaient avant staliniens
ou je ne sais quoi et puis des gens
qu'ont posé les armes mais en gardant
quelque chose en eux qui fait que quand
un gars comme moi enfin le un certain
Jean-Luc Mélenchon apparaît dans la
sphère politique des tas de gens qui ont
rien à voir forcément avec moi qui sont
dit ça je suis d'accord allez on essae
encore un coup avec lui et euh dans la
manière de voir je m'étais fait une
comment on va dire la religion
républicaine OK et puis en même temps tu
essayes d'en trouver une version
personnelle parce que bon encore une
fois la religion républicaine c'est tout
le monde mais moi moi moi moi tout seul
dans mon coin quand j'ai peur quand j'ai
soif quand j'ai faim quand j'aime quand
je suis désespéré moi qu'est-ce que je
fais que comment je m'en sors de ce
monde bouclé alors je fais de l'Albert
Camu il faut imaginer CIF heureux je
roule le rocher alors décrit ça
magnifiquement et peu importe l'effort
qu'on fait pour pousser la pierre suffit
alors il dit la lutte pour les sommets
suffit remplir le cœur d'un homme
d'accord alors bon c'est pas la crapahu
pour le sommet de la hiérarchie hein
c'est la lutte pour remonter le caillou
en haut puis comme il a été condamné par
les dieux hein parce qu'il a donné aux
hommes le savoir quand il arrive en haut
avec sa pierre tou la pierre redescend
lu redescend la remonte bon tu réfléchis
tu te dis euh
d'accord bon c'est bien c'est c'est beau
puis après tu
dis remonter une
pierre alors Camu décrit tu pousses la
pierre tu sens la pierre dans ta main tu
es une fois ou deux peut-être mais 10
fois 20 fois 30 fois et je sais pas
pourquoi je m'imaginais que c'était la
nuit tu vois un monde où il y a pas où
il y a une pénombre en quelque sorte il
y a jamais il y a pas le soleil il y a
pas d'oiseau il y a pas de tu es là tu
pousses ta pierre ça me va pas moi c'est
pas moi
ça et alors j'ai tranché et à ce moment
de ma vie je pense toujours que le monde
est vide de
sens je pense toujours qu'il est habité
par l'absurde comme le décrit Albert
Camu je fais ma petite synthèse avec
avec Sartre je pense que c'est
l'existence précède la conscience que
c'est la la bon tout ça
mais je me
dis la vraie réponse à l'absurde c'est
pas de pousser une
c'est d'introduire du sens à un endroit
où il y en a
pas la vraie réponse à l'absurde de
l'existence c'est le quichotisme c'est
quichot sur son bourin crevard avec sa
lance et qui affronte des dragons comme
tu le sais dont certains disent que ce
ne sont pas des dragons mais seulement
des moulins
prouve-le tu parles tu aucun rapport
avec le sujet là et c'est une bonne
introduction il y a quand même plein de
sujets on va pouvoir rebondir dessus de
dragon de moulin d'intelligence
artificielle de conscience quand quand
j'entends Christine lagard dire on va
introduire de l'intelligence
artificielle pour comprendre d'où vient
l'inflation quand tu entends ça ça te
fait ça te fait penser à quoi je pense
que et je ne'en suis pas surpris
elle n'a pas une conscience très claire
de ce qu'est
l'intelligence et si c'est au point
qu'elle ne sait pas d'où vient
l'inflation il y a vraiment un très
grand problème de l'avoir nommé banqure
centrale du 2e pb du monde
hein voilà elle sait en fait qu'est-ce
qu'elle fait quand elle fait
ça se moque de où se moque de toi tu es
là tu dis bon l'intelligence
artificielle moi je pourrais dire
attendez attends copain j'ai trouvé une
autre idée on va jouer à pilou facein ou
bien on va lancer desd c'est à peu près
aussi stupide la source de
l'inflation à cet
instant c'est évidemment le fait que
toute une série d'acteurs qui n'ont plus
de limite qui ne sont plus limités par
rien
abusent d'une situation pour augmenter
des prix et augmenter des marges et ils
le font et leur comportement nous
rappelle que dans la vie des êtres
humains tout est rapport social et tout
rapport social contient un rapport de
force c'est-à-dire si j'ai le pouvoir de
vous faire payer plus cher je le fais
alors il y a une je peux recevoir une
limite dire à mon pote c'est tellement
cher que plus personne achète bah c'est
pas le cas et tu peux te dire oui
jusqu'à présent je faisais des bons
profits euh en vendant beaucoup et ben
là je vais peut-être vendre moins c'est
le cas en France hein
mais ça va y aller parce que je me
prends des marges comme ça ça dure un
temps le temps de l'assigner alors
peut-être que tu seras mort à la sortie
peut-être que tes gosses auront pas
mangé assez et que par conséquent ils
seront moins bien développés que vous
serez plus malade mais quoi tout ça
c'est la vie c'est du commerce pour eux
c'est tout le temps du commerce ce qu'il
y a de terrible dans le
capitalisme parce que il a des secrets
le capitalisme il a une dynamique
interne ça sert à rien de dire le
contraire quand on le discute c'est
normal toutes les étapes de l'histoire
de l'humanité tu discutes ce qu'on est
en train de faire bon c'est
normal mais on a cru un temps nous
autres he dans notre famille idéologique
il y a eu un grand débat est-ce que les
contradictions internes parce qu' a des
contradictions ce capitalisme il faut
qu'il produise plus il faut qu'il
augmente sans arrêt les moyens matériel
qui met en mouvement et en même temps
bon il faut qu' qu'il augmente la part
de la richesse qu'il capte pour lui lui
c'est très malin le capitalisme vit du
travail gratuit des gens c'està-dire tu
produis pendant 10h ben naturellement
qu'on pas te filer la valeur de ce que
tu as produit pendant 10h bon alors tout
le monde va dire oui il faut d'abord
retirer l'investissement les matières
premières ok ok on a compris mais ça
laisse un bon resterait c'est quoi c'est
du travail gratuit que un protagoniste
s'approprie donc c'est un rapport de
force si tu te laisses faire elle en
prend beaucoup si tu te laisses pas
faire et bon voilà il y a un compromis
le capitalisme il a des limites internes
mais celle à laquelle on navait pas
pensé c'est maintenant qu'elle arrive en
tout cas il a montré qu'il a une
capacité à rebondir et que le grand
débat sur est-ce que la crise allait
venir d'une d'une contradiction interne
et plaf le capitalisme allit s'écrouler
il y a un
débat au début du 20e siècle dans le
mouvement socialiste enfin à l'époque
tout le monde est socialiste he il y a
un grand débat là-dessus avec des thèses
différentes comment on s'y prend bon
alors évidemment chacun avait un peu
tendance à avoir midi à sa porte suivant
le pays si on était dans un pays de
capitalisme assez avancé on voyait bien
les contradictions ailleurs on il y a
qu'à attendre ça tombe bien comme ça pas
besoin de faire trop d'effort on va
marchander on va discuter les autres
pays bah on disait non non faut faut un
raccourci alors ça te donne des pches
bref il y avait un débat
euh mais le capitalisme a survécu à
toutes les crises qu'il a déclenché pas
des petites hein la crise de de 1914
celle qui va conduire à la guerre
mondiale tu avec unee tuerie de masse
une guerre mondiale on a à peine fini
avec ça que bon à part qu'on s'est tapé
la grippe espagnole qui a tué plus de
monde que toute la guerre euh derrière
arrive la crise de 29 rebolotte une
guerre mondiale et puis une crise tous
les 10 12 ans là actuellement c'est tout
10 12 ans on a une grosse crise et comme
le système est maintenant des centaines
de fois plus imbriqué et globalisé à
l'intérieur de la sphère numérique c'est
d'une violence totale hein comme ça pas
tou ça part d'un bord ça arrive à
l'autre la crise de 2008 a failli tout
le temp mais à chaque fois hop il
rebondit pourquoi parce que il détruit
et la reconstruction il se refait du
gras dessus ça c'est déjà on est obligé
de tenir compte de sa capacité à
rebondir tu crois en Ricardo la
destruction créatriceah la preuve ça
s'est produit donc c'est plus un article
de fois c'est des choses qu'on voit hein
euh mais à chaque fois le on peut dire
les contradictions sont élevées à un
niveau supérieur je l'ai dit ass cez de
fois hein mais maintenant je dis bon ok
la crise est de plus en plus grave il
est tellement grave que tu te demandes
comment appeler un truc pareil depuis le
temps qu'on dit qu'elle est de plus en
plus grave mais là ce qu'on avait pas
prévu nous je termine rapidement avec ça
avant de revenir à la crise elle-même
euh telle que je je viens de la décrire
il a il a surmonté
ce qui nous devrait nous donner un
signal d'alerte il a surmonté en
exploitant les destructions qu'il
occasionnait et aujourd'hui ce qui fait
qu'il n'a pas de limite c'est que il
tire profit des dégâts qu'il produit je
donne dans le bouquin un exemple que
tout le monde connaît enfin beaucoup de
gens connaissent pas tout le monde mais
c'est l'histoire des abeilles alors à
cause des des pesticides il y a plus
d'abeilles bon alors c'est tout en CYC
d'AB bon il y a plein de trucs plus
d'abeille normalement il devrait y avoir
une crise majeure puisque 90 % des
légumes qu'on mange et des des fruits
ils doivent être polinisés il se passe
rien que fait le capitalisme
dit mais les abeilles oui oui c'est
sympa les abeilles mais nous on vous
vend des drones
pollinisateurs alors écoutez bien les
drones pollinisateurs ce qu'il a de bien
c'est que ils travaillent le jour mais
aussi la nuit pas les abeilles de et
mange rien donc ça fonctionne terciau
ils mettent le pollen bien mieux que les
abeilles c'est très précis et donc vous
avez plus de récolte et bon bref tant es
si bien qu'à la fin on est presque
content de pu avoir d'abeille puisque
grâce à pas d'abeille tu as des drones
pollinisateurs oui mais si tu as pas
d'abeille tu connais la suite les
oiseaux les machin et cetera et comme
l'écosystème est en tout le détruire à
un point le détruire à des dizaines
d'autres qu'on voit pas forcément tout
de suite enfin c'est quand même comme ça
qu'a commencé la 6e extinction du vivant
sur cette cette planète donc la
difficulté pour nous c'est de comprendre
àants que ce système ne connaîtra pas de
limite interne c'est pas à cause des
dégâts qu'il produit qu' va dire ah là
là les dégâts que j'ai fait il faut
arrêter on est en train de tout casser
tout pourrir parce que tout ce qui casse
tout ce qui pourrit trouve le moyen de
te vendre le moyen bon alors de le
réparer ou de mettre autre chose et ça
répand une idéologie c'est-àdire une
sorte de confiance absolue dans la
technique tout ce qui est technique on
va tout régler comme ça de manière
aveugle là dans les gens qui font la
critique de de mon bouquin d'ailleurs je
suis content qu'il fasse la critique de
mon bouquin y compris comme c'est
vraiment des gens d'accord avec Ren ce
que je raconte mais ce que j'aimerais
c'est que quand même ils critiqu ce que
je raconte et pas ce que eux croient
mais pourquoi pas je regarde la critique
et il y en a un par exemple qui dit que
mon livre c'est un livre qui croit plus
au
progrès alors je me suis dit c'est c'est
frappant c'est pour lui l'idéologie du
progrès c'est allez on fait quoi
on produit quoi n'importe quoi n'importe
quand n'importe où n'importe comment
c'est pas un sujet du moment que ça
tourne c'est bon ça fait de la vie ça va
aider il y a du boulot bon évidemment ça
fait du fric ça tout le monde le
comprend mais c'est pas écrit dans le
dans l'article critique mais moi je
pense que la difficulté maintenant à
affronter un c'est de dire si vous
n'arrêtez pas ce système là il contient
en lui-même la
catastrophe il la contient pour pourquoi
parce qu'il a besoin sans cesse
d'accélérer le rythme interne qui est le
sien l'argent se transforme en
marchandise qui se transforme en argent
et il faut que ça tourne de plus en plus
vite si bien que le capitalisme produit
son propre espace-temp vous comprenez
les gens ce que c'est un espace-temps
c'est quelque chose qui lie les rythmes
et les distances par exemple je résume
j'ai habité Massie à quelle distance
Massie est-il de Paris M pas les EAU ah
c'est deux communes différentes ne
faites pas la bêtise de N confondre
Massi pas les EAU c'est deux communes
différentes je dis Massi pourquoi parce
que je connais la distance 20 km 20 km
20 km dans une bagnole c'est rien
d'accord 20 km à vol d'oiseau mais tu es
pas un oiseau moi non plus conclusion
quelle est la distance Massi Paris si
c'est à 3h du matin 25 minutes si c'est
à 6h du soir
1h30 donc la distance n'existe pas en
kilomètres elle existe en temps de
transport d'accord un espace c'est
quelque chose qui lie l'espace et le
temps et le capitalisme a créé son
espace-temp alors toi tu passes ta vie à
courir pour aller chercher tes gosses à
l'heure ici tout le monde s'en fout hein
la boîte elle se soucie pas de ça
ensuite quand tu arrives bah le service
administratif il est fermé c'est normal
la personne qui est faut bien aussi
qu'elle vive bref vous vous êtes les
résidus de l'espace-temp capitaliste
débrouillez-vous lui il obtient ce qu'il
veut c'est-à-dire livrer les choses à
temps pour que le truc tourne voà avant
en avant en avant bon et dans cet
espacets c'est ça à quoi je
réfléchissais comment on peut essayer de
rendre ça concret pour le comprendre et
peser dessus en fait cet espace-temps
c'est juste un rythme le temps n'est
qu'un rythme par exemple ton
anniversaire veut dire il y a un an
prochain ouais he un an non c'est juste
le rythme si la terre tourner plus vite
ça mettra moins d'un an donc en réalité
c'est un rythme le temps n'existe que
par rapport à référent et par rapport à
un cycle quand tu réfléchis comme ça tu
comprends ce que veut dire le mot la
règle verte on ne prend pas la nature
plus que ce qu'elle peut reproduire
c'est moi qui a fait la formule donc je
la connais sauf qu'il y a un problème de
quoi tu parles mon gars pas plus qu'elle
ne peut reproduire dans quel délai et
c'est là qu'on s'aperçoit de en quoi
consiste réellement la crise écologique
déclenché par le capitalisme c'est une
collision des rythmes je donne un
exemple comme ça tout le monde comprend
il faut une seconde pour produire un sac
en plastique il faut 4 siècles pour que
le sac en plastique se dissolve ce
rythme là ce choc de rythme fait que tu
as des sacs en plastiqu partout et comme
ça paye pas de les dissoudre ils sont là
mais je pourrais donner d'autres cycles
où on voit que le capitalisme a inversé
le
temps toi moi tout le monde on aime tous
le sucre pourquoi parce que nos ancêtres
il y a 390000 ans ceux qui avaient le
goût du sucre d'avir receveur reçoiv la
petite récompense quand tu manges du
sucre tu tu es content mais ceux qui
mangeaient du sucre avaient une
meilleure énergie donc ils vivaient
mieux et ils avaient plus d'enfants donc
c'est cette caractéristique génétique
qui s'est reproduit c'est donc un
critère d'évolution depuis 390000 ans
positif et le capitalisme il vient il te
met du sucre partout pour que tu a envie
d'en bouffer dans la charcuterie dans
les pâtes dans bien sûr dans les gâteaux
mais dans tout des quantités telles que
ils ont déclenché une alors c'est des
quantités il faut avoir idée hein c'est
40 kg par an qu'on en mange chacun 60 kg
quand tu es aux États-Unis c'est quelque
chose et résultat le cycle humain s'est
trouvé renversé ce qui était un facteur
de progrès biologique devient un facteur
morbide c'est-à-dire tout le monde est
malade diabète obésité et cetera voilà
une inversion de cycle qui est lié à la
contagion de l'espace-temp capitaliste
pourquoi parce que toi avant tu mangeais
de de mortadelle comment arriver à te
convaincre d'en bouffer une 3è une 4è et
une 5è du sucre donc pour que le cycle
de ma vente et de l'accumulation du
capital se fasse faut que tu manges du
sucre voilà comment le un
espace-temp explose tous les autres
cycles et les domine et voilà pourquoi
ça va être difficile d'arrêter tout ça
je me fais l'avocat du
diable le capitalisme on l'entend
souvent énormément de gens de la
pauvreté c'est une question de facteur
temps de faille spatioemporelle c'est un
argument commercial est-ce que ça
tiendra dans le temps est-ce que c'était
pas simplement un coup de boost à force
de taper dans lesénergie fossile certes
ça a sorti beaucoup de gens de la la
pauvreté mais quand on va inverser la
tendance de consommation énergétique ça
risque de remettre beaucoup de personnes
dans la difficulté là il y a trois idées
la dernière étant ça nous mettre dans la
mouise la seconde était euh il y a quand
même des gens qui vivent mieux et la
première c'était c'est grâce au
capitalisme bon donc on pourrait
dire on pourrait comme ça pour dire oui
mais c'est un peu comme si euh quelqu'un
qui est en train de s'arracher les
cheveux ou de se peler la peau à la fin
a plus de peau en quoi tu vas dire c'est
génial tu c'est avoir tout saccagé on
dirait waouh le pied il y a des gens qui
ont pu aller boire du Coca-Cola ah
génial ne me dis pas qu'on peut tous
boire du Coca-Cola ouais et tu peux en
plus tu peux monter dans une bagnole et
dans ta bagnole tu peux faire un bouchon
de 2 km et faire 3 heur de plus de
transport ah bon ne me dis pas que on
peut être aussi heureux que ça
c'est-à-dire quand tu mets bout à bout
tous les les les dysfonctionnements
inombrable le sacage le
l'appauvrissement intellectuel et tout
que ça comporte tu peux dire
au minimum ça mérite discussion pour
faire le bilan après tu regardes en quoi
consiste la fameuse richesse alors c'est
là que je discute ce concept ce n'est
pas vrai pourquoi par exemple tu vas
prendre un pays et on va dire Monsieur
Mélenchon regardez ce pays avant il
avait un PIB produit intérieur brut de
allez je dis n'importe quoi on va dire 1
million de dollars et maintenant
regardez il en fait 50 vous pouvez pas
dire que c'est pas bien alors toi tu es
là tu dis merde
mais qui c'est qui les a les 40 de plus
là ah c'est pas tout le monde c'est
juste un petit nombre primo ah ouais et
les autres avant qui ramassai les 10 ils
sont où ah bah pas de bol il y a bien
fallu qu'on prenne leur terre pour
planter du maïs du maïs ils mangent du
maïs ces gens-là ah non non pas du tout
il mangent du sorgo alors les gens qui
mangent du sorgo vous leur faites
planter du maïs qu'est-ce que vous
faites avec le maïs ah ben on le vend
pour nourrir des poules en Chine donc
vous êtes en train de me dire que tous
ces gens ne peuvent plus vivre de leur
culture il y a plus d'agriculture
vivrière mais ils doivent être contents
parce qu'on vend du maïs et qu'il y a
des poules chinoise qui le
bouffe alors si tu es de bonne foi tu es
obligé de dire bah ouais c'est ça le
système et puis tout le monde va y
trouver son son compte le gars qui porte
le sac de maïs celui qui plante mais
c'est pas vrai donc tu as eu un
appauvrissement général des millions de
gens dans des taudis vivant de Combin de
toutes sortes parce queil y a peu
travail et une économie qui n'est pas
tournée vers ce qui compte c'est-à-dire
nourrir des gens je rappelle que
l'agriculture en principe le but c'est
de manger c'est c'est pas de produire
bon tu manges plus et puis si par hasard
tu manges tu es dans une situation
inouie c'est que les poules chinoises
noui avec ton ton maïs elle te coûte
moins cher quand elles reviennent dans
un bateau qui les a transporté que la
poule que tu as en bat de chez toi celle
qui est en bas de chez toi elle a mangé
plus que donc tu ne peux même pas
espérer t'en sortir parce que tu
pourrais te dire ah benah écoutez moi
vos histoires j'en ai assez les poules
je m'en occupe moi-même pas de bol tu
peux pas donc le système a mis toute une
économie en impasse et il se donne
l'apparence de fonctionner mais ce n'est
à chaque fois que par transfert ceux qui
ne mangent plus ici font manger quelque
chose d'autre ailleurs qui fait manger
d'autres gens et ainsi de suite et le
circuit comme ça tourne en produisant
non pas plus de richesse mais plus de
misère le nombre de misérable est
toujours plus grand en valeur absolue et
en valeur proportionnelle la plupart du
temps tu sais pas de quoi tu parles
parce que on te divise un PIB par tête
de pipe or diviser un pb un PIB par le
nombre d'habitants d'un pays c'est sympa
pour les ma mais sociologiquement ça
veut pas dire ça veut rien dire du tout
maintenant si ajoute une dernière chose
c'est qu'avant tu croyais que tu
exportais du maïs nous autres les
Français ont fait ça à l'exporte du maïs
on est contentexporte du maïs très bien
il y a plus que 3 00 paysans dans notre
pays il y a 3 millions d'étudiants il y
a 390000 paysans quand moi je suis né
des paysans c'était la première classe
sociale du pays bon tu crois que tu es
tu que tu expédies du
maïs tu le crois et ben tu te trompes
c'est pas du maïs que tu exportes c'est
de l'eau l'eau dont tu manques parce que
pour faire pousser ton maïs dans des
terres qui n'étaient pas prévu pour ça
il faut arroser arroser et arroser donc
tu exportes gratuitement de l'eau au
dont tu as besoin alors c'est quoi le
bilan à la sortie tu peux dire oui mais
quand même bon ça a fait marcher les
bateaux ça a fait marcher je sais pas
quoi mais en réalité ça nous a tous
appauvri et la meilleure des preuves que
ça nous appauvrit tous c'est qu'on est
un petit nombre à vivre dans des
conditions telles que si tout le monde
vivait contre nous comme nous nous
serions instantanément tous morts donc
c'est bien la preuve que le système
marche
pas si je te dis guerre économique ça te
fait penser à quoi est-ce que tu connais
les mécanismes de guerre économique
est-ce que tu peux me donner des
exemples de guerre économique à l'heure
actuelle oh il y en a tellement il y en
a tellement mais ça revient toujours à
une
idée la guerre économique on parle de
guerre économique souvent entre les
nations hein mais tu as aussi la guerre
économique entre les
entreprises donc c'est vrai que c'est un
monde qui est basé sur la compétition et
on te dit la compétition d'ailleurs
c'est très bien parce que ça oblige à
faire des progrès
bah oui alors c'est toujours pareil tu
fais la balance moi la compétition il
rien contre à condition que ça empêche
pas la solidarité P le gars qui est
vraiment de droite il va me dire à moi
la solidarité j'ai rien compte je suis
pas une bête so les mêmes pour tout le
monde
oui oui déjà mais je veux dire dans les
sentiments personnels bon mais
essayons de
réfléchir un argument qui vient tout le
temps sur la table on prétend que la
puissance c'est la puissance
économique la puissance économique te
donnerait le droit de faire ce que tu
veux si tu es d'être libre quoi comme tu
es puissant tu fais ce que tu veux c'est
important la définition hein en réité tu
t'aperçois que pour être puissant et le
rester tu es obligé de déployer toute
une armada pour protéger ton rapport de
force changer les lois mettre des armes
inventer des frontières des gardes
frontières des bon changer les règles du
jeu à intervalle régulier pour que tu
puisses continuer à en profiter et pas
les autres
donc la compétition porte une idée de la
puissance que moi je juge
dépasser c'est-à-dire mon pays la France
quel est l'intérêt pour la France
pourquoi devrait-elle vouloir être
puissante pour pouvoir rester libre
c'est quoi libre libre ça veut dire je
fais ce que je veux en gros
he fais ce que tu veux mais tu t'es
trompé les gars là tu dis plus la même
chose faire ce que tu veux ça veut dire
tu es indépendant tu es autonome donc tu
veux être indépendant et autonome c'est
une autre affaire tu es indépendant et
autonome pourquoi faire pour que ta
population ait mieux indicateur de
développement humain autonome et
indépendant tu as besoin de science tu
as besoin de savoir-faire tu as besoin
tu as besoin de plein de choses
maisénergie oui mais tu as tu as besoin
donc commence par discuter des moyens
dont tu as besoin pour voir comment tu
peux te les procurer c'est pourquoi moi
je pense que dans la diplomatie
internationale surtout quand on est pas
70 millions c'est-à-dire on est
allez trois gros quartiers de shanghï
quoi hein bon où on pourrait prendre New
Delhi puisque maintenant c'est la
première population du monde elle est en
Inde donc il vaut mieux miser au bon
endroit si tu comptes être puissant en
faisant plus de bagnoles que les Chinois
tu as perdu si tu veux être puissant en
tu peux pas donc faut être il faut être
si tu veux être autonome et souvrin faut
procéder autrement donc tu as besoin de
coopération pas de conflit donc faut
coopérer et donc défin une stratégie
politique des causes communes je viens
de voir et je te propose faire un truc
ensemble ça fait basculer plein de
concept je dis même pas que je vais être
solidaire avec toi mettons que tu es
rien je viens de voir vous êtes juste
nombreux ah d'accord être nombreux pas
nous vous êtes jeunes pas nous nous on
est de plus en plus vieux notre pays ah
vous êtes jeunes alors les jeunes ça PUL
s'ils ont envie ils ont envie
d'apprendre de savoir et cetera donc on
va faire non pas de la solidarité on
pourrait dire solidarité hein mais
j'aime mieux un autre concept c'est
l'entraide parce que il y a un copain un
copain m'a dit dans la solidarité on a
toujours un qui tend la main dans
l'entraide c'est on a besoin les deux
l'un de l'autre quoi le rapport on est
on est là comme comme tu dirais dans une
famille ou je sais pas quoi moi ou dans
un couple c'est de l'entraide donc une
stratégie une diplomatie une nouvelle
diplomatie correspondant au problèmes du
21e siècle qui fait que on est tous dans
la même mise du changement climatique
peut-être qu'on a perdu la partie hein
mais si on veut s'en sortir je vois pas
comment on peut faire autrement que de
dire bon on en commence par accrocher ce
qu'on peut faire ensemble alors
exemple aujourd'hui le monde entier se
créolise c'est-à-dire qu'on vit tous de
plus en plus d'une manière semblable il
y en a qui ça fait hurler hein et puis
d'autres qui se disent bah si c'est
comme ça voyons ce que ça donne hein pu
toute façon tu as pas le choix alors
donc ça se fait tout seul alors tant
qu'on les créolise en anglais ça leur va
hein ils sen rendent même pas compte il
se baladent dans les rues de Paris la
moitié des boutiques ont des n en
anglais anglais dans la conversation
maintenant il y en a une quantité
incroyable et après il viennent dire oui
Mélenchon veut nous créoliser attends je
m'excuse vous êtes déjà créolisé les
petits vous en rendez même pas compte
bon donc cette créolisation il faut être
habile puisque c'est puisque c'est un
phénomène universel comment je fais pour
y trouver mon compte dedans je peux
couper avant
vas-y parler de solidarité dansent
traide alors que ça fait 250 ans qu'on a
planté dans la tête d'autres puissances
de la ronqueur de la peine de la
vengeance quand on voit la politique
extérieur chinoise ce qu'elle a subi ce
qu'elle a ce qu'elle fait tu as vu comme
l'histoire pardon jeis juste je
t'interromps dans l'interruption il y a
un humour noir dans l'histoire les
anglo-saxons ont abattu la puissance
chinoise au 19e siècle laad l'adope et
les ont obligés à se droguer et
maintenant prétexes de
liberté du commerce évid mais regarde le
CLIN d'œil de
l'histoire les deux les États-Unis qui
aujourd'hui affronte la Chine hein sont
en proie à la plus grande crise liée à
la drogue que personne n'est jamais
connu jusque là c'està dire je crois
qu'ils en sont à 120000 morts par an de
produits de drogue et chez les Chinois
pour l'instant on a l'impression que
c'est plus leur problème d'accord bon
non mais c'est pour dire j'ai on ça cet
après-midi discuté à quelques uns à
propos de des trafics internationaux et
de la masse de fric qui circule par les
trafics il légau qui structurent des
secteurs du capitalisme dans le monde
entier et des discussions de certains
copains mais peut-être ça viendra un
autre moment dans notre échange à tous
les deux de d'un gars un président de la
République il m'a dit tu le sais
Mélenchon que chez moi c'est la guerre
de la drogue je le sais président et
alors il me regarde il dit tu sais que
je peux pas la gagner
silence alors j'ai dit bah je sais pas
ça dépend je sais pas quoi dire en fait
intimement je pense qu'il a raison il
peut pas la gagner et il me regarde il
me dit alors si je peux pas la gagner
pourquoi je la
continue bah tu sais plus quoi dire il
me dit tu comprends si je continue j'ai
droit au trafic de drogue l'armée les
commandos
paramilitaires ceux qui s'y opposent
leur
commando il me dit sur le terrain ça me
fait c armés qui se tapent dessus je
fais quoi moi là-dedans je dis bah
écoute écoute président tu feras bien ce
que tu voudras mais je te préviens nous
on nacceptera pas dit je sais mais ça
sera ton problème pas le
mien réfléchissez les gens d'avoir
laissé des secteurs du capitalisme
sauvage cruel comme ça accumulé mais
c'est pas la première fois avant c'était
l'esclavage le coup d'avant il y a pas
un vice qui n'est pas produit une
accumulation du capital qui lui est
permis de se répercuter
bref trafic de
drogue trafic des armes en France 11
millions d'armes circule hein tu
t'imagines ce que c'est aux
États-Unis trafique des êtres humains
alors de ça motus et très peu par
contre les révoltes urbaines le magasin
qui a brûlé le alors ça en avant des
heures dur rant à la télé regardez c'est
insupportable c'est inacceptable c'est
bon oui c'est vrai c'est pénible mais
pendant que vous faites les marioles à
vous occuper de sujets qui sont
Epsilon de la réalité parce que si tu
soupçonnes qu'il y a des bandes tu peux
toujours courir après le type que tu as
attraperé au pied de l'immeuble tu vas
recommencer tous les jours parce que
tous les jours il y en aura un autre
tant que tu t'es pas attaquer au trafic
lui-même et tu t'attaques pas au trafic
si tu réponds pas à pourquoi les gens
font ça au point de départ voilà et donc
pourquoi les gens font ça parce qu'
parce que c'est la pas du gain parce que
c'est c'est de l'argent facile au prix
de la mort d'un paquet d'autres et quand
on veut cibler le consommateur c'est les
gens se droguent parce qu'il y a un
mal-être les gens se droguent parce que
ils ont besoin de s'évader non parce que
les êtres humains sont fait comme ça
parce que au début pour rêver tu
proposes des chansons et des sur les
murs et puis après tout d'un coup il y
en a un qui s'est qui a bu je sais pas
quoi il a laissé les fruits ça a pourri
ça a fait de l'alcool tu picoles waouh
tu pars ailleurs tu as vu un autre monde
au début tu sais pas tu dis mais il
existe sans doute tu as des
civilisations où on dit il y a le monde
du rêve les gars il y a le monde là et
puis il y a le monde du rêve et dedans
j'ai fait si j'ai fait là j'ai vu les
dieux ils m'ont parlé ils m'ont dit de
faire c ils m'ont dit de faire là je le
fais bon les êtres humains sont des
rêves des des êtres d'imaginaire et de
mal-être parce que un être humain il est
équipé d'un d'un équipement qui est la
meilleure des choses et la pire un
cerveau et ton cerveau il ne fait qu'une
seule chose ton cerveau il est
paranoïque à ta place il passe son temps
à calculer qu'est-ce qui va arriver les
êtres humains sont tous confronté à une
forme plus ou moins intense d'angoisse
du futur celui qui a l'angoisse la plus
basse c'est celui qui est le plus en
harmonie avec le monde dans lequel il
vit parce que les choses sont en place
tu les repères c'est l'automne c'est
l'hiver il y a des très clair et il se
passe ceci puis moi je ferai ça et puis
comme c'est l'automne je fais ça ta vie
tout d'un coup elle est sécurisée par ce
cycle là que tu maîtrises hein bon et
puis après ben voilà au boit un coup ah
bah ça fait de l'effet et puis après il
y en a un autre c'est la fumette et puis
et puis après et celui qui a le plus
grand malaise dans une existence qui n'a
pas de sens ou dont le sens c'est de
pousser un rocher gris et où tu as même
pas un seul dragon à combattre qui
pourrait y mettre
bon alors je suis pas en train de dire
que ce droguer est une attitude naturel
mais ce que je voudrais dire c'est que
nous sommes tous portés à aspirer au
rêvees et que si pour notre malheur nous
touchons un produit qui nous rend
dépendant de lui parce que c'est ça la
drogue ce qu'on lui reproche c'est de
rendre les gens dépendants de quelque
chose qui est détruit et bien à ce
moment-là quand tu as mis le doigt dans
l'engrenage ça y est tout il passe et
jusqu'à ce que tu sois broyé et
déchicteté la preuve les États-Unis
d'Amérique vous vous avez vu les images
des gens qui consomment la dernière
drogue là les zombies là ah mon Dieu
comment c'est poss possible bon alors on
était sur moi j'ai interrompu
l'interruption revenons revenons à les
la compétitiontait ouais c'est presque
ça depuis 250 ans 300 ans je dirais ces
graines de rancune
d'agressivité de compétition je dirais
est-ce que maintenant on n pas dépassé
un point de non retour en terme de
coopération de stand la main de
confiance est-ce que derrière on n pas
tellement armé mentalement on a
tellement braqué des puissances des
populations entières avec des phénomènes
de guerre économique on les a mis sous
sanction on s'est démerdé pour faire
tomber leur économie pour mieux
exploiter leurs ressources est-ce qu'on
se retrouve pas maintenant avec
tellement de haine les uns envers les
autres que pour faire redescendre la
pression on va être obligé de se [__]
sur la gueule une bonne fois pour toutes
alors ça fait partie des risques he
alors commençons d'abord par voir que la
compétition pardon c'est pas tout le
monde qui la veut hein il faut quand
même se rappeler de ça la compétition
est organisée par ceux à qui elle
profite on n'est pas en train de parler
d'un match de foot où c'est le meilleur
qui gagne là on parle de compétition
économie qui brassent des milliards qui
brassent du pouvoir bon il y a ceux qui
l'organisent bon ah faut pas l'oublier
les guerres sont pas déclenchées par les
peuples hein euh c'est des gens qui les
déclenchent qui se connaissent très bien
entre eux qui se font pas la guerre et
puis il chauffent les eutres à blanc
alors ils tombent sur la possibilité ou
non bon de de de chauffer les gens à
blanc rappelons-nous les guerres
internes qu'il déclenchent par exemple
en montrant du doigt toute une
population à cause de sa religion et on
t'explique du matin au soir qu'à cause
de leur religion ils sont dangereux on a
fait ça avec les Juifs maintenant avec
les musulmans à chaque fois il y a
toujours une bonne raison ou bien c'est
la couleur de peau ou bien c'est donc le
puissant lui il sait qu'il est en petit
nombre il faut donc toujours qu'il
trouve le moyen de diviser les autres en
petit nombre mais je viens à la question
culturelle et je suis d'accord pour dire
qu'elle est centrale il suffira pas de
dire aux gens dis donc je vais
t'expliquer pourquoi la baisse
tendantielle du taux de profit oblige le
capitaliste à diminuer les payes et pour
pouvoir y arriver faut qu'il divise les
travailleurs Nani nana et quand je te
l'ai expliqué tu as tout compris c'est
le messianisme
tu as tout compris t tu deviens
révolutionnaire c'est pas vrai les êtres
humains négocient leur rapport à
l'exploitation à travers un filtre qui
s'appelle la
dignité tu connais la phrase de
alexandretier vas-y sur les leaders il y
en a un qui émerge parce qu'il se bat
pour la dignité des plus
faibles moi je crois ça je pense que
c'est un puissant ressort
donc c'est en tout cas c'est un exemple
qui nous montre tu veux personne va se
faire tuer pour un différentiel
d'inflation pourtant c'est meurtrier
mais par contre pour une idée aussi
confuse que la liberté ou la fraternité
tu des gens qui se font tuer bon les
êtres humains ont heureusement pour eux
une capacité à à inclure des paramètres
qui sont sensitifs sentimentaux et
autres alors tu me dis est-ce que on a
tellement poussé les gens qui sont
devenus
incapables de solidarité on va dire pour
faire bref par angoisse je te prends un
exemple ouis là en ce moment on est en
train de se castagner avec les Russes la
génération qui est au pouvoir et la
génération qui est aux manettes c'est la
génération qui a subi l'effondrement de
l'exunion soviétique avec plus rien dans
les supermarchés pas de chewingwing-gum
les jeux des gamins à mettre des à
collectionner des des papiers de
chewingwinggum venant d'autres pays
parce que ils étaient ils avaient plus
rien le fait que la grand-mère fasse
nourrir toute la famille en bonlie
Moscou parce que c'était la seule à
faire encore que à à avoir des patates
on retrouve les souffrances des pays à
travers leur art
culinaire quand on voit cette jeunesse
qui est maintenant au pouvoir angoissé
de revivre ça comment on peut lui faire
passer le message h on va pas vouloir
faire à l'envers vous inquiétez pas ayez
confiance surtout pas moi je leur
diraiis pas ayez confiance parce que
comment ils sont fait avoir la dernière
fois ça va quoi tout tout le monde en
Europe on pareil pour les
Chinois ou oui mais en Europe pour là
c'est l'interruption dans l'interruption
encore en Europe on a une sorte d'espèce
d'arrogance on se croit tellement
intéressant tellement bon et alors les
autres la fin de l'URSS peu de gens
savent que ça a été un désastre humain
immense un recul de l'espérance de vie
des milliers de gens qui sont suicidés
le Piccolo comme jamais et cetera et
cetera mais donc mais je veux reste sur
le la question comme vous la formuliez
il y a un instant comment refaire du L
mais parce que parce que c'est la
question cruciale on ne peut pas séparer
les êtres humains de la culture qui les
lit donc si on les dresse
continuellement à dire chacun pour soi
et ça sera bien pour tout le monde hein
c'est-à-dire ce que disait margarte
satcher elle dit la société existe pas
il y a que des individus et si les
individus se font une bonne vie ils la
feront pour tout le monde ça ira bon
voilà c'est margarte sat cher mais et
c'est une idéologie ça on est tous comme
ça on a une idée dans la tête bon
Anthony guidens qui était le théoricien
qui collait à prblire tu vous rappelez
de ça quand on a dit à Madame Sacher la
grande championne du libéralisme on lu a
dit quelle est votre plus grande
victoire elle aurait pu dire ou j'ai
cassé la tête au mineurs j'ai défoncé le
syndicalisme anglais elle aurait pu dire
ça j'ai défoncé les Argentins ouais
c'est la réponse qu'elle fait elle dit
ma plus grande victoire c'est Tony bler
c'est-à-dire un socialiste qui fait la
politique de droite et dis là j'ai gagné
parce que je lui ai pourri la tête et il
est persuadé que c'est comme ça qu'il
faut faire là la plus grande victoire du
capitalisme c'est chaque personne qui se
dit moi je vais gagner et je m'en fous
des autres débrouillez-vous que chacun
fasse son bonheur et ça ira bien pour
tout le monde et il y a un très beau
livre qui s'appelle la nouvelle loi de
la jungle le gars il est plutôt
anarchiste il est pas trop de moi j'ai
des accointances avec les anarchistes
mais je ne suis pas de de culture euh
bon et mais il est magnifique F son
livre Pablo servine ça s'appelle la
nouvelle loi de la jungle entraide et
lui il démontre que contrairement à ce
qu'on raconte le vivant vit beaucoup
plus d'entraide que de n'importe quoi
d'autre alors les champignons qui font
les liens entre les arbres les animaux
un animal ne tue que pour manger et la
quantité dont il a besoin il y a que les
êtres humains pour tuer des milliers de
bestioles et s'en [__] il y a que des
êtres humains pour mettre 50 millions de
d'oiseaux dans une broyeuse parce qu'ils
sont pas du bon sexe c'est des des
poulets hein on a 50 millions tu te
rends compte ce que c'est dans une
boyeusee criche CR criche des trucs
vivants hein bon il y a il y a que les
c'est une culture de pouvoir faire ça
bon et servine nous dit une chose que je
crois moi qui m'a qui m'a guidé à partir
du moment où j'ai lu son livre je me
suis dit il il m'apprend une chose un
type de comportement est une
contribution direct au rapport de force
sociale autrement dit si j'entre dans la
logique de l'entraide un je seraiis plus
fort de au cas où la civilisation Vienne
ce qui va se produire à s'effondrer par
morceau parce c'est comme ça que ça va
se passer et bien on sera plus fort et
lui servine dit si vous y entrez avec la
mentalité néolibérale vous allez encore
plus souffrir de ce qui va vous arriver
et ça m'a vraiment il m'a convaincu et
je dans le bouquin j'évoque à la fin
quelque chose que j'aurais pas osé faire
autrefois il y a un chapitre sur la
morale et je dis la politique et la
morale ne peuvent pas être dissociés par
parce que nos motivations pour agir sont
des motivations morales individuelles la
peine l'empathie pour les autres la
souffrance que tu ressens quand tu vois
souffrir et je dis le mal c'est un
modèle un comportement économique dont
tu sais qu'il est nuisible à un très
grand nom mais tu le fais quand même
parce que çaarrange toi le bien c'est
tout ce qui va permettre d'être ce que
j'appelle la vertu c'est-à-dire ce qui
est bon pour toi c'est ce qui est bon
pour tous c'est dur hein comme idée
attention je suis pas en en train de
prener la sainteté là mais je dis ça
c'est des repères qui peuvent vous aider
à agir ne dites pas que vous vous en
fichez et ça m'amène à des critiques par
rapport à ce que j'ai pu croire dans ma
jeunesse hein bon il y avait un livre de
de Lon Trotski quand j'avais 20 ans
qu'on lisait qui s'appelait leur morale
et la nôtre et Léon explique que bon la
morale tout ça c'est aussi à rapport de
force et cetera et puis ça se termine
par en gros il dit la fin dans certains
cas dit-il ça c'est euh justifie
dialétiquement les moyens alors moi je
dis non aucun moyen ne peut être pensé
indépendamment de la fin les moyens
c'est de la fin tout de suite donc pas
question et il y a un très beau livre
maintenant trop tard il il est plus en
circulation s'appelit les militants et
leur morale mais donc dans mon livre à
la fin je dis ça voilà la vertu
c'est-à-dire ce qui est bon pour tous et
ce qui est réellement bon pour moi et ce
qui n'est bon que pour
moi c'est à bord qui coupe aborde la
question de de la morale comme j'ai pu
aborder comme une composante de la
manière de vivre ensemble alors tout à
l'heure il y avait dans la question un
truc à quoi j'avais pas répondu tu as
dit oui mais si jamais on doit se passer
de tout ça on va vooir une drôle de vie
ouais je sais pas en quoi elle
consistera toi non plus je sais pas
pourquoi tu en parles parce que on
aurait dit aux petites bandes il y a
390000 ans qui erraent et qui se
divisaient parce que les êtres humains
c'est des singes hein spéciaux mais
c'est des singes les singes chaque fois
qu'ils sont plus de 25 ils séparent en
deux bandes bon alors nous on a dit les
êtres humains c'est 150 mon œil c'est
pas vrai la séparation se fait avant ça
continue encore aujourd'hui moi j'ai vu
de mes yeux une tribu se coupée en deux
et quand tu vas pour discuter avec les
gens de sair pourquoi ils séparent ils
te le disent pas parce que c'est un
secret tu vois c'est c'est c'est quelque
chose qui qui tient plein de petits
paramètres bref si on avait dit à ces
gens-là il va y avoir une
époque où l'époque que tu vis il
l'aurait pas CR cru qu'est-ce que nous
allons devenir nous autres les êtres
humains à 10 milliards d'abord est-ce
qu'on va y arriver est-ce
que je vais donner maintenant des
exemples je veux pas que ça fasse peur
c'est pas mon truc hein de faire peur
aux gens mais quand tu te dis en
Australie le feu prend ils ont vendu la
flotte à une boîte ils disent il y a le
feu on veut la flotte le gars il dit moi
la flotte je vous la vends il fait
quelle taille votre feu là il vous faut
combien de litres ça fait temps PE
il brûle la surface de la Belgique et la
flotte
elle reste dans la poche du mec au
Canada il brûle l'équivalent de si j'ai
bien compris de la grisse et ainsi de
suite et qu'est-ce qui regarde comment
ça se passe le feu prend je vais prendre
hawaïi le feu prend dis ah bah
formidable tout est prévu alerte il y a
le feu oui au début alerte il y a le feu
et mince il va plus vite que prévu
allô il y a plus d'électricité
il y a plus de poteau il y a plus de
téléphone donc toi tu vois le feu qui
arrive mais c'est pas ça qu'ils nous ont
dit tu sautes dans ta voiture tu te mets
à rouer tu dis mais la voiture c'est une
bombe si jamais le feu me rattrape tu
poses ta bagnole au bord de l'eau et toi
ch tu sautes dans la mer voilà comment
ça c'est fini
l'effondrement le le secrétaire général
de l'ONU vient de dire ça l'effondrement
est commencé vous allez pas le voir tout
de suite mais déjà ça avance comment ça
se passe et ben le feu prend plus
électrique le talon d'achile de notre
société c'est l'électricité enlève
l'électricité qu'est-ce que tu fais
réponse rien rien tout simplement rien
tu ne peux plus rien faire enlève le
pétrole
euh je reviens je reviens tu peux non tu
peux fonctionner sans le pétrole tu peux
plus fonctionner sans l'électricité fais
le tour de chez toi et demande-toi
qu'est-ce que tu fais marcher au pétrole
et qu'est-ce que tu fais marcher à
l'électricité tu vas voir ta vite fais
le bilan l'agriculture avec le pétrole
quand même beaucoup je je reviens sur ma
première question de remettre du lien
contre les puissances alors qu'elles ont
été chauffées à blanc pendant des
décennies les Arméniens les a les
asées les
Arméniens sont en train de se
faire c'est c'est une épuration ils se
font
virer on voit les mémés les gamins c'est
l'épuration ethnique c'est c'est c'est
dramatique ouais c'est ce qu'on a laissé
faire en Europe alors et il y a il y a
il y a les Turcs d'un côté qui poussent
un côté il y a les autres de l'autre qui
pousutre côté mais une c'est les
populations civiles qui Mor le corp
comment on fait pour
réconciler les classes politiques sont
contraintes de donner l' du peuple
c'estd voe pour moi je suis président du
pouvoir d'achat et ça ira mieux demain
ou ENF en azerbajan vote quand on a le
temps il faut voir comment il faut voir
aussi les pipelénergéti qui passent dans
la région mon viux si vous voulez
prendre les guerres de notre époque
suivez les pipelines il y en a jamais eu
autant là tout le monde fait des phrases
et du bruit avec sa bouche ah il faut
arrêter il faut des carboner d'accord
177 projets de pipeline dans le monde il
y en a jamais eu autant c'est-à-dire que
c'est ce que je disais tout à l'heure le
système peut pas se corriger ce qu'il y
a de plus fabuleux c'est de sortir du
pétrole et de le vendre à des gens qui
ont pas le choix pas d'autre choix que
de l'utiliser mais je viens sur Arménie
et azerbaïjan d'abord faut y aller mollo
parce que c'est pas les gens à qui on a
dit E gens vous êtes d'accord pour faire
la guerre non c'est des gens qui
dirigent qui se sont dit tiens nous pour
des raisons X Y Z qui sont liés à
l'histoire profonde à des intérêts
matériels au passage des pipelines
pourquoi tu crois qu'on a été en
Afghanistan la liberté du monde je me
rappelle j'étais à l'époque j'étais
socialiste les écoles pour les petites
filles non oui les écoles pour les
petites filles et puis la liberté du
monde qui se jouit à Kabou hein non le
pipe foutait le camp vers la Chine et
les Américains pouvaient pas supporter
un truc pareil et comme on avait vendu
le passage du du PA pas une compagnie
Argentine et amériican Argentine et que
les types ont changé d'avis au début ça
baignait comme dans l'eau entre les les
talibans qui avaient le pouvoir et les
Américains du jour où il change de
compagnie alors c'est terminé c'était la
guerre les petites filles le reste bon
je dis ça avec moi j'ai de l'amertume ça
durit 20 ans cette guerre d'accord
c'était un dépottoir
l'Afghanistan les Américains quand ils
savaient plus quoi faire d'une arme il
acheté la-bas comme ça l'explotter et
terminé tu as pas besoin de la démonter
ils ont jeté la plus grosse bombe
conventionnelle de l'histoire de
l'humanité l'équivalent d'un Hiroshima
ils l'ont balancé là-bas personne n'a
jamais su pourquoi faire quelles avaient
été les conséquences c'était la guerre
en tant qu'
activité correspondant à un cycle de la
marchandise c'est terrifiant là quand on
parle de l'Arménie et de
l'Azerbaïdjan ce ne sont pas les gens
qui ont décidé de faire la guerre c'est
des dirigeants qui tous sont impliqués
par des intérêts bon et puis évidemment
de l'argent mais le monde est cul
par-dessus tête et tout le monde s'en
fout les Ukrainiens qui se plaignent
d'être envahis par les Russes à juste
titre vendent des armes à l'Azerbaïdjan
qui vient d'envahir l'Arménie où tu en
entend parler c'est quoi ta source bah
c'est ma source et ma source qu'à
regarder c'est facile à
savoir les Ukrainiens vendent des armes
bon alors et le résultat c'est ça
l'Azerbaïdjan env la question c'est quoi
ta source ben là je l'ai plus là mais je
veux bien la donner c'est pas un
problème je veux pas dire de conneries
l'attribu à une source plutôt qu'à une
autre vous la saviez pas ah bon ben j'ai
peut-être dit révéler un secret sans me
rendre compte par que j'ai beaucoup de
choses qui passent tu sais les insoumis
il y en a partout donc quelque chose que
je sais pas bon en tout
cas l'univers entier est
scandalisé par une invasion à juste
titre hein don moi j'ai qui suis pas
spécialement un ami des Américains
j'avais dit l'UTAN n'entre pas en
Ukraine les Russes n'entrent pas non
plus les Russes sont entrés bon 2 heures
après moi j'ai dit j'ai condamné
donc c'est pour dire que je comprends de
quoi il s'agit et je ne peux pas
accepter comme français qu'on recommence
en Europe à régler les problèmes en
passant les frontières hein donc c'est à
la fois toute ma sympathie pour ceux qui
sont envahis mais en même temps je suis
membre et j'ai été élu d'un pays envahi
quatre fois dans un siècle d'accord donc
nous autres dans notre histoire
nationale de français bon alors
nous-même on en a envahi d'autres alors
ça n'avait pas tout à fait la même
signification quand c'était la grande
révolution mais les pays qu'on a envahi
pour les coloniser si ça avait bien la
même signification on entrait chez des
gens et on disait dorén avant c'est nous
qui commandons et cette mentalité on l'a
pas vraiment perdu he si on regarde
comment ça se passe on va peut-être en
parler dans un instant comment Monsieur
Macron a réussi à nous [__] à dos
toute l'Afrique mais enfin bon pour
revenir à l'Arménie il est clair
que quand tu regardes cette situation
aux
Arméniens pardon pour revenir aux
Arméniens oui à l'Arménie aux
Arméniens moi je cache pas ma que ma ma
sympathie va du côté des
Arméniens pourquoi parce qu'on a une
histoire commune mais Mélenchon alors
qu'est-ce que tu il faut avoir une
histoire commune pour s'entendre avec
toi bah ouais déjà ça aide 1 2 je vois
bien qu'il est l'agresseur TR je suis
conscient de la difficulté parce que le
territoire du hautkarabach est dans les
frontières reconnues internationalement
de l'Azerbaïdjan d'accord donc faut pas
raconter d'histoire mais l'engagement
qui avait été pris par tout le monde
c'est écoutez cette situation n'est pas
claire donc CZ le feu on se tape pas
dessus on discute et on finira par
régler le problème et puis à un moment
donné les dirigeants monsieur alief qui
est le le fils de son père qui était
lui-même alief membre du bureau
politique du parti communiste de l'URSS
puis premier président de ce pays et
c'est son fils qui est le second
président bien dit B la situation m'a
l'air bonne personne regarde il y a pas
trop de problème et est affaiblie voilà
R sont censés faire la maintien de la
paix oui et tout le monde il y a un
groupe qui a été constitué où il y a les
Russes les Américains les Français les
Français on oublie ça compte plus les
Américains et les Russes ils se parlent
pas entre eux les Russes vont me donner
un petit coup de main et puis a mes amis
tures qui vont m'aider donc il se dit
c'est une bonne occasion de récupérer
l'autorité sur mon territoire et comme
disait
l'autre une fois que tu es arrivé jusque
là pourquoi tu t'arrêtes vu que la
résistance est faible peut-être que les
Arméniens ont surestimé leur capacité de
résistance parce que la dernière fois
c'est eux qui avaient gagné et non
seulement l'Azerbaïdjan a récupéré
effondré la structure administrative et
politique de cette région mais a envahi
l'Arménie
elle-même donc là on est dans une
situation où normalement on devrait
voler au secours de l'Arménie en disant
et alors c'est là que tout un récit sur
le monde s'écroule j'ai pris l'exemple
de l'Ukraine il y a un instant mais
jusqu'à présent le récit c'était le choc
des civilisations ça c'est les
Américains qui racontaient ça alors il y
a la civilisation occidentale et puis
les musulmans alors ils en faisait un
paquet et les musulmans étaient des
ennemis sur la terre
entière alors là il y a un problème ça
colle pas alors on a dit oui mais c'est
des musulmans par paquet sunit et chiit
zut ça colle pas non plus pourquoi les
Iraniens aident les Arméniens qui sont
chrétiens et les Turcs aident les l'AZ
l'Azerbaïjan qui est musulman comme eux
mais pas tout à fait de la même branche
donc ça veut dire que la grille de
lecture à partir du choc des
civilisations et du choc à l'intérieur
des religions elle correspond à rien et
c'est ce qu'on a on n' pas cessé de dire
que ce qui constitue les intérêts
communs d'un groupe humain qui
aujourd'hui sont tous organisés en
nation va toujours être plus important
que n'importe quel autre paramètre et
que ce qui va jouer c'est ce qui sert
cette communauté les dirigeants disant
voilà pourquoi il faut envahir voilà
pourquoi faut pas faire si voilà
pourquoi et c'est pourquoi moi je n'ai
jamais cru à la salade le monde
multipolaire alors on dit c'est
formidable le monde multipolaire vous
comprenez avant il y en avait deux il y
en avait un de trop et maintenant c'est
bien parce qu'il a les États-Unis donc
enfin on c'est à quoi se référer et
d'ailleurs monsieur bouchep avait dit
nous nous venons faire la guerre en Irak
parce que c'est le nouvel ordre mondial
et maintenant il y a un patron et c'est
nous bon bon il a pas vraiment dit ça
mais si il a dit ça il a dit c'est le
nouvel ordre mondial et c'est nous qui
allons vous vous expliquer pourquoi il
faut faire comme ça bon alors la vérité
derrière il y a tout le monde a sorti
les violons pour dire il nous faut un
monde multipolaire parce que deux quand
même c'est un peu trop visible un
c'était pas supportable mais moi j'ai
toujours dit partout je suis passé vous
rêvez un monde multipolaire nous les
Européens on a connu
1885 on s'est partagé le monde avec les
Allemands d'accord les Belges et les
anglais et on s'est découpé tous les
territoires à coloniser c'était les
Allemands qui avaient trouvé cette idée
pour qu'on se les répartisse bon alors
comme on était déjà sur le terrain et
pas eux on a pris le plus gros bout et
ils ont pris ce qui restait qui les
intéressait ils ont d'ailleurs commencé
à expérimenter les méthodes de massacre
de masse et ensuite ont prospérer bon
tout ça on l'a vu mais ça s'est passé le
monde multipolaire on l'a vu nous c'est
le monde multipolaire c'est les plus
puissants se mettent d'accord entre eux
etcrabouillent les autres puis après se
tape entre eux moi je n'ai jamais été
pour ça je suis pour un monde ordonné et
un monde ordonné c'est un monde où il y
a des lois consenti en commun et une
force qui appuie cette loi voilà donc on
a pas besoin de l'OTAN qui est le bras
armé d'une puissance les l'ONU a tous
les défauts du monde on est d'accord
mais elle existe et je rappelle à ceux
qui regardent ça avec du mépris que
l'ONU c'est la suite de la Société des
nations qui s'était cassé la figure et
la Société des Nations on la crée après
la guerre de 14 en disant plus jamais on
se fait la guerre pour régler un
problème donc moi je continue à dire on
ne règle aucun problème de frontière par
la force ni celle de la frontière de
l'Ukraine et de la Russie ni celle de
Azerbaïdjan et de l'Arménie ni aucune
frontière raison pour laquelle j'avais
dit en Europe si j'avais été élu nous
ferons une conférence des frontières
alors évidemment qure ou c bien
atttentionnés qu'on dit ah mélenchant
met en cause des frontières non
Mélenchon vous dit les frontières en
Europe seront remises en cause les
frontières à l'intérieur des nations et
entre les nations et si vous ne le
comprenez pas vous n'avez qu'à regarder
quels sont les intérêts qu'opposent les
gens comment ça se fait qu'aujourd'hui
les Polonais décident de ne plus
exporter d'armes aux Ukrainiens alors
qu'on est il paraît que tout le monde
était amis contre les Russes à cause du
marché des céréales et ben oui et le
marché des céréales parce qu'il y a les
élections bientôt et qu'il faut avoir le
vote des agriculteurs fa nous y voilà
donc si nous n'avons pas des règles du
jeu si nous n'avons pas le moyen de le
faire respecter alors nous aurons un
monde en guerre et il est possible qu'en
effet ça se termine par la guerre
générale ça pourrait être le cas en
Europe en Europe les frontières fragiles
je souhaite pas qu' attention je suis
pas en train de dire qu'elles sont
tellement fragiles que j'ai un souhait
sur la question mais je vous ai dit au
début de la querelle au début de la de
la l'invasion russe vous verrez ce que
vous allez voir parce que ce n'est pas
clair entre polonais et ukrainien et
j'ajoute ce n'est pas clair entre
hongrois et ukrainien et ça c'est des
histoires faut un peu lire l'histoire
pour comprendre pourquoi c'est comme ça
après on pourrait dire mais j'espère
qu'il neur arrivera rien les T belge est
un état fragile entre flamand et wallon
la la Grande-Bretagne est un état
fragile entre les écossais qui pourrait
bien revoter une nouvelle fois sur
l'indépendant sans oublier l'Irlande où
la majorité est passé au shinfine des
deux côtés donc un jour ou l'autre la
question de la frontière qui les sépare
elle va être posée la Catalogne on en a
entendu parler à un moment donné ils ont
même fait ils ont voulu faire un
référendum et l'Europe avait répondu si
vous votez l'indépendance vous êtes plus
en Europe ah ben voilà qui est nouveau
Barcelone ne serait plus en Europe ne
serait plus dans l'Union et ainsi de
suite nous les français on est en train
de discuter nous les français on est les
champions du
pipo nous on est la République française
unitaire ouais depuis toujours ouais
grâce à la révolution en effet pas de
bol la Polynésie française elle a un
gouvernement c'est plus un État unitaire
la
Nouvelle-Calédonie kanaki pour certains
Nouvelle-Calédonie par le vote elle a un
statut spécial avec un con Congr du
territoire et un gouvernement la
Martinique a une collectivité locale la
Guadeloupe en a deux la Guyane a une
collectivité locale la Réunion en a deux
la Corse attends j'y viens mais c'est
pour dire la Polynésie il y a bien
marqué française Polynésie française
elle dépend de l'article 74 de la
Constitution qui délègue toute une
partie de l'autorité de l'État en plus
tout le monde arrive à comprendre que
quand tu es à l'autre bout du monde
décalé de 13h bon bah euh peut-être que
c'est pas depuis Paris qu'on va prendre
les décisions les plus intéressantes sur
un territoire dont les Français savent
pas qu'au total d'île en île il est
aussi étendu que toute l'Europe rien que
la Polynésie française la surface et
toute l'Europe bon donc nous ne sommes
plus un État unitaire et dans ces
conditions qu'est-ce qu'on fait soit on
peut le nier ou bien dire ben je parle
de la nouvelle réalité pourquoi c'est
nouveau et cetera bon la Corse vous
prenez le problème par le bout que vous
voulez et vous arrivez toujours au même
résultat à savoir que majoritairement la
population corse si vous croyez à la
démocratie fait confiance aux
autonomistes aux indépendantistes et ils
ont élu trois députés de ce côtélà donc
moi je suis allé écouter ce que disent
les trois députésimagine que je suis
président de la République j'aurais pu
l'être alors on me dit il y a un
problème encore il manquit combien de
votes pour arriver au deuxème tour déjà
il m' manquéit 410000
rien quoi c'est comme ça tu vois
l'histoire qui te passe au bout des
doigts bon qu'est-ce que j'aurais fait
alors on m'a dit il y a un problème
encore ça peut plus durer bon fait quoi
tu envoyer la troupe non je fais pas ça
je fais pas ça c'est pas ma conception
c'est pas ma vision du monde et c'est
pas ce que veulent les cors ils veulent
pas le choc la violence donc que demande
les cors disje donc é voir c'est pour
moi c'était pas rien d'aller voir
l'ancien président de l'Assemblée qui
était un
indépendantiste et puis après bon le le
le le monsieur Gilles Siméoni qui est un
homme qui facilite les choses par la
qualité du contact qui s créé avec les
gens et puis les députés cors qui
étaient à l'Assemblée assis au-dessus de
nous du bloc insoumis là on était 17 à
l'époque et les trois cors ils étaient
au fond derrière donc j'allais souvent
bavarder avec eux à qui Viva Michel
Castellani qui bon on parle on parle et
des choses descendent eux ils me
voyaient comme un horrible jacobin qui
allait mettre tout le monde au pas
suivant la caricature qui est faite de
moi et moi je me disais mon œil oui
autonomiste en fait en fait bon bref on
parle et on on parle
et je me dis je vois ces hommes je vois
qu'on vote pour eux qui regagne
l'élection suivante et la suivante et je
me
dis ces gens-là ils portent quelque
chose qui est la vérité du moment et de
l'histoire en ce moment en
Corse qu'est-ce quiil demande l'article
74 ah l'article 74 la Polynésie
française à l'article 74 qu'est-ce qu'il
y a de commun entre les deux une chose
fondamentale l'insularité c'est des îles
une île il y a une un ensemble de
conditions qui se réunissent dès que tu
as une île tu as une mentalité tu as une
culture tu as des relations avec le
continent solidarité aussi absolument et
en plus là c'est une île qui est faite
aussi de beaucoup montagne de la
montagne alors la mentalité du
montagnard c'est quelque chose he tout
autour de la Méditerranée tu fais le
tour si tu traverses la Méditerranée tu
vas tomber sur les Berbères qui sont
dans les montagnes vu que il y a 1000
ans de ça les Arabes sont arrivés par en
bas les Berbères qui étaient là sont
montés dans les
montagnes bref il faut comprendre
l'histoire et la culture des gens pour
savoir quoi faire donc moi à ce
moment-là j'ai réuni les les plus
Jacobins des miens he les plus dur de
dur il y en a et je leur dis bonc
écoutez les amis si on gouverne
qu'est-ce qu'on va faire on va pas vaut
mieux savoir maintenant qu'attendre
d'être dessus euh bon on discute entre
nous c'était un peu chaud et moi je dis
écoutez je vous propose de faire comme
moi allez les voir et discuter avec eux
parler regarder et et après on reparle
ils l'ont fait on se retrouve et je
viens avec mon argument l'article 74 et
on parle de la nation française et de
son éventuel
démembrement et on tombe d'accord tous
ont dit bah nous on va être d'accord
avec eux l'article 74 si nous gagnons
les élections l'article 74
s'appliquera mais c'est des choses qu'il
faut manier avec
précaution la Corse c'est pas la
Bretagne c'est pas la même situation et
quand je vois qu'à peine les cors ont
réussi à entrebailler la porte de
l'autonomie aussitôt tu as les autres
qui disent ben nous on veut pareil et
ben la réponse est non je ne suis pas
d'accord pour queil y ait aussi
l'article
74 dans dans le casadre la Bretagne
parce qu'on est dans une autre situation
et alors encore moins pour la
collectivité européenne ou prétendu tel
d'Alsace hein bon parce que alors là ça
bat toutous les records de ce que moi je
ne peux pas supporter du point de vue de
de l'histoire de France et de la
nécessité quand même de faire peuple en
commun alors il y en a des sujets
difficiles à ce sujet là on parle de la
France mais on peut parler du
démembrement des États-Unis d'Amérique
et cetera mais là pour on reste sur la
France on a des discussions moi je suis
un homme de gauche donc je peux pas être
d'accord pour le droit à la
différenciation comme l'a vendu Macron
c'està-dire alors chaque région va
décider de sa loi sociale
alorsonéit pour rien de siècles
d'histoire de construction d'une loi
d'avantage en commun
de micro qu'est-ce que j'ai fait j'ai
déplacé il est bon là il est bon
l'ingénieur du son micro vas-y parle un
peu
attendsing qu'estce que j'ai fait j'ai
bougé trop vite ça
en direct je
bien après on coupera coup pas jamais
rien même ça
tu mais
qu' regardeo ça en de tout Casseron
machter j'en profite de abonnez-vous à
notre page euh soutenez-nous sur tipi
euhh c'est important c'est grâce à vous
qu'on est très indépendant qu'on peut
faire des longues vidéos sans pression
sans coupure pub sans sans
monétisation sans être obligé d'être
dépendant de quelqu'un c'est grâce à la
communauté grâce à votre
PEP et et ça y est tu es bon là ou tu
veux que je raconte une histoire de de
cuisine attends il va remettre son
casque vas-y remets-moi ton cas j'ose
plus bouger non si j'espère que tu vas
pouvoir bouger est-ce que au niveau du
son tu es bon on est magnifique donc je
je termine ce que j'étais en train de
dire euh
euh la question de l'unité de la loi euh
est une question qui n'est pas simple à
régler hein mais qu'on doit régler moi
je préviens tout de suite je ne serai
jamais d'accord pour que il y ait une
différenciation au niveau de la loi
sociale les droits sociaux et cetera ou
alors ou alors seulement dans un cas
qu'on appellerait le principe de faveur
c'est-à-dire on rétablit comme c'était
avant tu pouvais pas avoir un accord de
branche moins bon que la loi plus bon
oui meilleur tu pouvais pas avoir un
accord d'entreprise moins bon que
l'accord de branche meilleur oui donc je
seraiis d'accord pour qu'il y ait de la
différenciation à condition que ça soit
meilleur
exemple exemple avec l'Alsace chaque
fois que je dis ça peut pas aller le
Concordat tu as toujours un gros malin
pour dire oui mais Monsieur Mélenchon
est contre le droit social alsacien tu
m'as mal écouté j'ai pas dit ça j'ai dit
le Concordat je ne suis pas d'accord
pour qu'on finance la religion mais la
loi sociale de sécurité sociale de
l'Alsace je suis pour qu'elle soit
appliquée à toute la France parce
qu'elle est bien meilleure que la loi
sur la sécurité sociale pour le reste du
territoire de de notre pays donc on
pourrait dire le droit à la
différenciation à condition que ce soit
meilleur que la loi commune si c'est
meilleur que la loi commune ok si c'est
moins bon non alors ça c'est pour la
France après je sais pas si les Écossais
votent ce que ça va donner je sais pas
ce que ça va donner si les Irlandais
votent aussi sur leur unité voilà on
revient on revient à comment pacifier
les nations qui ont été chauffé à blanc
par le commerce par les haines
instrumentalisé par X ou Y
la diplomatie on en est où la diplomatie
française la diplomatie entre les
peuples est-ce que c'est pour maintenir
le vernis est-ce que ça sert réellement
à quelque chose est-ce qu'on a un corps
diplomatique qui a failli est-ce qu'on a
un renseignement qui a
failli est-ce que je vois que tu te
mares
vas-y je te laisse commencer
alors non mais je me marre pour la même
raison que vous parce que
bon sur le plan du renseignement là on a
battu quelques records de malrenseignant
hein bon mais commençons par le début
parce que c'est une question grave et
sérieuse d'abord il faut être clair sur
ce qu'on veut sinon on peut pas y
arriver si c'est juste développer du
catéchisme du genre oui oui il faut être
bon bon ça marchera jamais un truc
pareil ça marche jamais non faut s'y
prendre par le bon bout d'abord il faut
un cadre je le redis je le répète qui
t'a rabaché on a besoin de l'ONU
deuxièmement vous avez raison de dire on
est arrivé à un tel point que c'est une
un renversement complet du discours que
de dire on arrête la compétition pour
faire autre chose moi j'ai réfléchi à ça
et essayé d'y répondre en me disant si
je présidais le pays comment je m'y
prendrai il y a commençons par où est
notre on là je parle en français hein
bon bah notre première zone comment dire
de bonne entente bah c'est là où on
parle la même langue c'est-à-dire là où
il y a la langue commune la francophonie
j'aiiniste c'est pas l'Europe pourquoi
parce que tu coopères tu peux coopérer
avec tout le monde mais tu coopèes plus
facilement là où tu parles la même
langue parce que l'échange est direct la
mise en commun est directe et puis c'est
un espace de comme j'ai dit de
créolisation la créolisation ça veut
dire qu'on mélange c'est imprévisible la
crolisation ce que ça donne donc nous
les français on a un un intérêt pour
notre pays particulier pour les endroits
où on parle français parce qu'ils sont
plus jeunes que nous parce qu'ils sont
plus nombreux parce qu'ils sont plus
imaginatifs nous on sait faire plein de
choses et on pourrait donc avoir une
logique d'entraide comment on s'entraide
si tu t'amènes en disant on vient
s'entraider tout le monde va dire très
bien on est au courant la dernière fois
que vous êtes venus on s'est entraîné
comme des fous vous avez embarqué tout
avec vous donc bon non il faut qu'on
vienne avec ce que moi j'appelle un
projet de cause commune bon si tu
réfléchis bien tu t'aperçois que il y a
de la matière
on va prendre un exemple nous les
français on entre en crise de l'eau on a
prévenu moi j'ai démarré ma campagne
comme ça ils s'en foutent complètement
comme de leur première chemise ou l'au
tu as qu'à en acheter le marché va
régler le problème tu as plus d'eau tu
as qu'à l'acheter bon alors Mayotte ils
aiment pas trop là ah non mais Mayotte
et puis la Guadeloupe d'accord et puis
et puis et puis partout o les réseaux
ont été à l'abandon alors
euh je prends l'exemple de l'eau parce
que il y a des pays qui peuvent nous
apprendre des choses par exemple là
demain je pars je vais au Maroc
euh le Maroc pourrait nous aider à faire
face à la crise de l'eau parce que eux
ils ont mis dans leur constitution le
droit à l'eau ils savent travailler ça
ils ont mis au point des choses des tas
de gens on des tas de choses à nous à
nous à nous apprendre et et c'est pas la
peine qu'on fasse les prétentieux on
sait tout mieux que tout le monde hein
c'est pas vrai à l'inverse on peut dire
bah nous on a des choses à mettre euh
quand je dis des causes communes c'est
ça par exemple on dit il y a une cause
commune l'eau très bien tous les pays du
petit bassin méditerranéen on se met
d'accord pour dire les gars les filles
on parle de ça comment on purge not trau
parce que on met tout dans la
Méditerranée comme dans un cloac
qu'est-ce qu'on fait comment on s'y
prend deio il y a un incendie qui a de
qui dans quel ordre on le fait qui sa
qu' aachète des avions combien tu en
achète toi combien j'en achète moi
qu'est-ce qu'on fait et cetera comment
on forme nos personnels nous les
Français entre-temps on parle toujours
de l'hypothèse ou c'est un insoumis ou
une insoumise qui préside hein bon donc
moi je sais une chose la lever en masse
dans le pays pour faire face à la
catastrophe climatique donc nous on aura
chez nous une garde nationale ou je sais
pas quoi on appellera ça une garde
citoyenne et au coup de siffler quand il
y a trop d'eau qui est tombé tout est
parti dans le truc tout le monde y va
creuse pelte posuse bref ce qu'on fait
dans les pourquoi parce que sinon jamais
tu
arriveras une la première fois qu' a une
catastrophe bon tout le monde fait face
la deuxième fois ça commence à être
lourd la 3è bah il vient qu' veut et
puis la 4e débrouille-to polo hein bon
tu manques électricité bah pay-toi une
un groupe électrogène tu manques d'eau
bah mets une citerne ah deux ouais c'est
mieux deux qu'une hein voilà
c'est-à-dire chacun en fonction de ses
moyens fera face à la catastrophe c'est
pas du tout l'idée que je m'en fais donc
on on met en commun on dit on a des
causes communes quelles sont nos causes
communes et là on est à égalité dire
chacun amène quelque chose l'autre bon
l'autre amène son truc toi tu amènes ton
truc ton savoir-faire ton matériel alors
nous les nous les français on sait faire
des avions mieux que tout le monde euh
bon et ben peut-être que c'est nous qui
allons proposer l'avion dont on a besoin
et puis on va le fabriquer autant de
fois qu'il faut pour que tout le monde
en ait pour faire du bombardement de
flotte sur les incendies peut-être qu'il
y a d'autres méthodes pour juguler les
incendies notamment des méthodes
préventives mais il faut y aller les
Garsin va taper la forêt à la déblayer
dedans faire des coupesfeu tout ça c'est
s'il faut payer tout ça euh bon bah le
temps qu'on paye c'est fini tout a brûlé
bon donc les la stratégie des causes
communes là j'ai pris des exemples un
peu simples mais on peut ça peut aller
dans nombreux domaines et puis nous les
français on peut mettre quelque chose
sur la table on dit écoutez voilà les
deux nouvelles frontières de l'humanité
c'est un la mer ça y est c'est parti on
est entré en mer on va l'exploiter et
cetera et cetera bon moi je suis pas
pour ça mais bon c'est parti il y a des
pays qui ont pas accès à la mer il y a
des pays qui ont accès à la mer et ils
ont déjà tout vendu c'estàdire tous les
poissons qu'il y a dedans ils l'ont
vendu à l'Union européenne laquelle vend
ça à des compagnies qui viennent avec
des trucs ramassent tout ce qu'il y a
dans l'eau tout jusqu'au fond du fond du
fond du machin le pauvre plus petit
escargot du coin quick il est pris alors
il y en a une partie ça se mange pas on
fait de la farine avec on donne à manger
au poissons d'élevage est-ce que vous
savez que bon tous dans votre imaginaire
vous avez l'idée que quand l'humanité
est passée de la chasse à à l'élevage il
y a eu un petit mieux hein et quand on
est passé de la cueillette à
l'agriculture pareil donc on est
d'accord he c'est une date forte dans
hisoire de l'humanité et ben en 2013 il
y a eu une date forte dans l'histoire de
l'humanité on a mangé plus de poissons
d'élevage qu'on en a pêché dans la mer
c'est-à-dire qu'on est passé de la
cuueillette à l'élevage bon ils ont tout
vendu c'est pas comme ça qu'on va gérer
la ressource donc nous les français il y
a des tas de choses qu'on sait faire à
propos de la mer des techniques des
bateaux des installation de toutes
sortes autre exemple l'espace il y a une
série de nation y compris du continent
africain parce que moi je suis polarisé
en ce moment sur le continent africain
pour une raison très simple c'est là que
va se faire le plus gros essort de
population de l'humanité donc on est
intéressé c'est à notre porte et en plus
on a une langue commune avec une partie
d'entre eux si on arrête de faire les
imbéciles et les arrogants qui fait que
du coup tout plus personne ne peut nous
supporter et que dans tous ces pays les
gens se disent ben il y a qu'à apprendre
à parler anglais parce que c'est ça la
nouvelle langue de la crolisation bref
je viens à ce que je disais cause
commune
l'espace l'Afrique s'est fait voler le
19e siècle à cause de l'esclavage le 20e
siècle à cause de la colonisation et le
21e siècle tous ceux qui n'accèdent pas
à l'espace ou qui n'ont pas les moyens
d'accéder à l'espace se font voler le
futur le futur de l'humanité il a lieu
dans cette direction on peut discuter
dire oui il faut d'abord s'occuper des
gens mais les amis c'est la même chose
s'occuper des gens et entrer dans
l'espace tous les jours d' manière comme
4000 applications qui partent des
satellites sont utilisées sur le
plancher des vaches donc la distinction
entre ce qui vient de l'espace et ce qui
vient de la terre c'est relatif
maintenant c'est déjà relatif alors nous
on peut avoir des causes communes on
sait faire les fusées les Français on a
l'endroit où les envoyer on a des
mauvais amis des faux amis les Allemands
qui ont pourquoi tu dis ça parce que les
Allemands ont accepté plombé ils nous
ont plombé le nucléaire c'est ça ils ont
plomber le la filière euh en en traînant
les pieds pour payer puis en décidant de
faire eux-mêmes des petits lanceurs qui
vont tirer depuis la Suède et pas depuis
le centre de de courou bref on s'est
partagé les domaines par exemple pour
les Satellite nous on faisait l'optique
et eux faisaent le son qu'est-ce qu'ils
ont fait dès le lendemain matin de
l'optique et du Son comme ça
l'accord c'est pas des bons partenaires
ils nous ont fait le même coup pour les
chars ils nous ont fait le même coup
pour à peu près tout et là il paraît
qu'on va faire un un avion avec eux
j'espère que c'est pas vrai parce que
c'est vraiment pas la bonne idée
heureusement du temps où il y avait
d'assaut Serge d'assut il voulait pas
entendre parler de ça alors peut-être
que maintenant ça a changé mais pour
dire je reviens à ce que je je je
précisais les causes communes on part
des causes qu'on a ensemble les causes
c'est par exemple comment on fait
ensemble alors on fait une université de
l'espace bah serait
francophone ça dire la langue commune et
puis on viendrait alors donc on arrête
de bloquer les visas des étudiants des
pays francophones parce que il vaut
mieux que des étudiants viennent en
France que des des Français aillent dans
des pays d'Afrique francophone à
l'université que nos profs ont se les
échange que l'année scolaire peut-être
on la mette en roulement bref il y a
plein de choses qu'on peut faire
ensemble mais ça ça suppose qu'on arrête
de donner des ordres à tout le monde et
de mal parler à tout le monde bon là il
faut dire ce qui est Macron nous a fait
reculer d'une manière incroyable des
fois c'est des petites choses il va au
Burkina tout le monde s'en rappelle le
Burkina il y avait eu une élection
président pridenti le président est élu
et l'opposition j'ai beaucoup de copains
là-dedans n'a pas discuté le résultat de
l'élection ça nous plaît pas tant que ça
mais bon il est élu et le gars il
respecte la situation bon le président
Macron y va ils vont à l'université
d'abord ils commence par trier ceux qui
rentrent dans l'université ceux qui
étaient dehors et qui voulait rentrer
poum poum poum les lacrimau et pendant
la soirée le le président Macron dit
déjà un truc pas
sympa quelqu'un lui pose une question
sur le fait qu'il faisait trop chaud et
lui dit je plus quoi une
connerie attends c'est quand le
président moment donné se lève P plus le
garséta très irrespectueux pour lui tout
ce qu' disait et à ce moment Macron dit
mais où il est parti il est parti
réparer la clime bon tu le vois en train
de faire ça avec Trump il aurait osé non
Trump lui pousé les épaules mais
pourquoi il parle comme ça quel que soit
le le bord la sensibilité politique d'un
burkinabé il est outré il est indigné
comme moi quand j'ai vu Trump enlever
les pellicules sur les épaules de Macron
dis mais pour qui se prend pour qui nous
prends tu nous touches ça va pas non bon
bref la même chose après en République
démocratique du Congo tu en penses que
tu veux mais tu es invité chez les gens
tu vas pas être mal poli qu'est-ce qu'il
fait il dit ah vous avez fait un
arrangement électoral il mieux th parce
que la République démocratique du Congo
ils ont su gérer pacifiquement des
transitions qui on est nous pour leur
dire comment ils doivent faire hein qui
on est de quel droit on parle comme ça
et surtout quand on arrive en RDC de
quel droit on tient les arguments d'un
agresseur de la République démocratique
du Congo qui est le le pays voisin
d'accord
bon et ben oui et euh tout ça ça nous a
fâché que tout le monde quand on arrive
au Maroc alors là c'est le pompon il y a
un tremblement de terre les
marocquains vu par les élites
soi-disant-el françaises au fond bon
c'est des pauvres petits malheureux quoi
hein alors on vient vous aider qu'est-ce
qu'il y a vous voulez pas pourquoi
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire et en avant
les émissions sur le Maroc peut-il
bénéficier de l'aide des Français et en
avant l'arrogance mais vous avez pas
l'air de vous rendre compte un que tous
les Fran tous les
Marocains immédiatement se sont mis en
mouvement va faire ça en France tu voir
si tout le monde va se mettre en
mouvement tout le monde se met en
mouvement pour aider de ils ont une
élite administrative
organisationnelle sans faire de bruit
sans faire de tam-tam sans la jouer à
Macron qui s'en va dans les Alpes
Maritimes il arrive en hélicoptère il
bloque tous les secours c'est une
pagaille indescriptible à cause
justement de son passage là rien de tout
ça le l'ordre la discipline pas de
pagaille le le tremblement de terre a
lieu la nuit le lendemain matin déjà
tout le monde est au boulot en train de
dire de quoi on a besoin on a besoin de
ceci on a besoin de cela qu'est-ce qu'on
nous propose pas venez tous allez tout
le monde arrive avec son camion son
machin son hélicoptère la pagaille non
ah cela il nous amène ceci ouais on les
connait non on n veut pas eux oui ok on
prend voilà ils ont travaillé ils ont
trié ils ont sélectionné et tout le
monde dit qu'ils s'en sortent mieux que
tout le monde voilà il y a eu d'autres
tremblements de terre je te prends
l'exemple de la covid la gestion par les
Marocains de la crise covid hein et ben
j'espère qu'il nous envoie des des des
des spécialistes en France pour nous
aider parce que ils ont pas eu de
pénurie de masque et ils ont su comment
traiter quand il y avait des cas
individuels quelque part tandis que nous
ça a été tout le monde reste à la maison
et résultat on s'est tapé quand même la
crise avec les pics de mortalité de la
covid les Marocains aussi ils ont ils
ont peut-être refusé notre aide parce
que on est un peu diplomatiquement bisb
viit avec eux parce que on est avec les
Algériens parce que aussi le sud du
Maroc on était pas clair avec eux
qu'est-ce que tu en
penses que de toute façon ça ne nous
donnait pas le droit de leur faire des
leçons d'accord le Maroc est un pays
indépendant souverain et il fait ce
qu'il veut et quand on on propose son
aide d'accord on commence pas à s'amener
en faisant beaucoup de bruit et de
tamtam hein genre toi de toute façon tu
saurais pas le faire donc le Maroc faut
se mettre ça dans la tête appartient au
marocains et ils font ce qu'ils veulent
et ils avaient des offres c'est ce qui a
été dit tout de suite il y avait des
offres qui étaient faites par toutes
sortes de pays hein tant mieux he qu'on
dit on vient donner un coup de main et
ils ont regardé ce dont ils avaient
besoin et ils se sont dit bah peut-être
qu'ils se sont dit j'en sais rien hein
maintenant ça tout ça c'est des choses
qu'on découvre en lisant dans la presse
en ce moment c'est super chaud he entre
les deux pays euh bon alors là c'est
pareil chacun une responsabilité moi je
suis pas d'accord pour que ça dégénère
avec le Maroc je suis pas d'accord tu
pas d'accord pour que les Marocains
j'espère qu'ils le savent croi que toute
la France est Macron moi jusqu'à présent
j'ai pratiqué une manière de faire à
l'ancienne je disais bon bah on critique
pas son pays à l'étranger et tout mais
lui Macron quand il y allait il s'en
pournait au français Goulois réractaire
depuis la Roumanie machin partout où il
passe il s'en prend à tout le monde il
se fâche avec les gens qui a là plus
avec nous qui sommes ici bon donc je ne
suis pas d'accord pour que les Marocains
pensent que au fond la France et bien ce
sont ces donneurs de leçons qu'on a pu
voir dans les chaînes d'information en
continu il y a eu une belle soirée à
laquelle moi j'aiétais très heureux
d'être invité qui était sur France 2 qui
était respectueuse qui écoutait qui
donnait des exemples qui montrait bon
bref mais tout le reste quand même ça va
quoi pendant 2 jours comment se fait-il
qu'ils ne veulent pas de notre aide et
vous allez vous calmer un peu qui vous
êtes pour parler comme ça ça vous vous
en rendez même plus compte de comment
vous parlez la presse la presse un rôle
dans les tensions qu'il a entre les
peuples euh ah bon ouais
énorme énorme il y en a tu as du mal à
croire que c'est la presse tu as
l'impression que c'est directement
l'ambassade qui écrit l'article quoi bon
il y a eu des articles sur le roi du
Maroc
bon il y avait pas un autre moment pour
faire ça bon le monde une tartine sur le
roi du Maroc très hostile très j'ai vu
un autre papier alors il y avait des
gens les malheureux il avaient tout
perdu bon tu un tremblement de terre
c'est l'horreur tout tombe sur la tête
tu sais pas c'est mectou c'est c'est
pour toi c'est pas pour l'autre cette
maison tombe pas celle d'à côté tu sais
pas pourquoi bon donc des gens qui ont
tout perdu et alors les gens racontai ça
dans une détresse et et à la fin il y
avait un un témoignage c'était mais
est-ce qu'on est vraiment des Marocains
nous tu dis mais attends e c'est pas le
gouvernement qui a fait le tremblement
de terre oh stop je relis papier je me
dis est-ce que les gens protègent je
veux savoir non pas du tout il
protestaient contre le malheur qui leur
été fait et le gars qui parlait de ça il
parlait d'autres choses mais c'est ces
manières de monter euh bon de renvoyer
dos à
dos c'est le truc du journaliste 5
minutes pour la victime 5 minutes pour
le bourreau tout le monde a parlé voilà
j'ai encore lu des papiers là il y a une
série dans le monde qui est
particulièrement crapoteuse euh qui
consiste à essayer d'exciter les uns
contre les autres euh bon moi je trouve
ça lamentable alors moi j'ai décidé que
j'irais euh bon ça c'est sû je suis
l'invité de d'une université à
Casablanca je vais aller présenter mon
bouquin je crois que c'est jeudi que je
fais ça avant je vais aller faire un
petit soit à Marrakech mais discret tu
vois je je viens pas pour voir on va
m'emmener c'est des gens qui ont dit on
t'emmène pour voir mais je veux pas le
moindre tu vois poussez-vous BL
Mélenchon hein ils ont déjà assez de
truc à faire et ceux qui m'invitent ce
sont les mes du coin j'ai tellement
tellement enfin bon moi j'ai des
relations spéciales avec eux tout le
monde le sait je suis né là-bas he donc
c'est un peu j'ai un lien qui est qui
s'explique pas comme toi avec peut-être
ton village natal ici là dans le périgor
je sais pas où mais bon bah moi c'est
Tanger qu'est-ce que tu veux c'est il y
a pas de villes comme ça dans le monde
donc voilà mais pas seulement peut-être
que si ça avait
été un autre endroit bon mais je j'avais
j'ai j'avais besoin je sais pas comment
dire ça j'avais besoin je sais pas
comment vous dire de de le faire quand
il y a eu le tremblement de terre
d'Agadir tous les hommes de ma famille
se sont mobilisés dans la nuit d'accord
à l'époque on avait tous le téléphone
vous l'aviez pas ici mais nous on
l'avait et ici vous étiez à faire des
signaux de fumée et nous au Maroc on
avait le téléphone bon et alors tout le
monde tac tac tac tac ça s'appelait d'un
côté de l'autre les bagnoles on a
commencé à remplir le matos et les
hommes sont partis mon P le téléphone à
Gadir hein qui c'est qui avait mis le
téléphone à Agadir pas à Agadir c'était
à Tanger parce que cétait on allait on
allait partir qui c'est qui avait mis le
téléphone à Tanger je crois que c'était
les espagnool c'est la teléphonica ou
peut-être les Marocains je me rappelle
plus mais à l'époque comme c'était pas
loin de l'indépendance ils avaient pas
encore bien tout en main hein alors on
avait le téléphone et donc mon grand
oncle mon cousin mon père mon toute la
famille tous les hommes dans les
bagnoles à descendre à Agadir alors mon
père et mon grand oncle pour contribu à
remettre en route la station de radio
télécommunication maritime et les autres
alors comme ils ont fait là là on m'a
raconté on m'a raconté à Houda et à des
autres endroits les gens la nuit
remplissent la bagnole de Fring de
bouffe et cetera ouf on y va on va
donner le coup de main magnifique si tu
veux la plus grande force là c'est là
que tu vois que la plus grande force
c'est l'entraide c'est l'entraide et les
gens discipliné sérieux j'ai vu à la
télé j'ai pas vu moi ça j'ai vu à la
télé les gens qui faisaient la queue
mais kom pour donner le sang personne
bronche bien en rang tu vois un après
l'autre dans l'ordre ça se fait
magnifique vraiment ils ont été magique
à apprendre deux donc le roi le roi a
donné le sang aussi c'est bien possible
oui oui bah il paraît alors moi je suis
pas assez proche pour savoir qui fait
quoi
hein il paraî que c'est en personne lui
qui dirigeait les opérations avec son
fils mou
Hassan qui est un jeune homme qui jouit
d'une très grande admiration dans dans
le peuple marocain parce que il paraît
qu'il parle cinq langues qui
m'impressionne beaucoup moi qu' en parle
que deux et encore en balbuiant
l'anglais ça fait TR et bon et puis il y
a tout un personnel politique
administratif culturel bon ils savent se
débrouiller quoi je dis tout ça pour un
petit peu que le T baisse en France hein
faut apprendre à nouveau à respecter les
autres à comprendre que du temps a passé
que la population marocaine s'est
multipliée par 4 depuis la période de
indépendance que les gens ont été à
l'école que il y a une élite euh des
tbibes des architectes des ingénieurs
que eux ils ont mis la cons la la l'eau
dans la Constitution par la France des à
cœur euh o il y a de tout quoi il y a
tout tout ce que tout le monde sait
faire bah les Marocains aussi savent le
faire c'est vrai pour les marocains mais
pas que pour eux c'est vrai pour plein
d'autres peuples où il faut avoir un
autre mode relationnel il faut arrêter
avec l'arrogance ah c'est pas difficile
à comprendre quand même si tu viens en
disant à faire des choses ensemble
lesquelles par exemple quand je suis
allé au Burkina moi je suis allé voir
les les mouvements avec lesquels j'étais
en phase hein le balai citoyen et cetera
après on m'a amené on m'a dit B on vous
invite à l'université Monsieur Mélenchon
venez nous nous présenter votre vision
du monde bon bah c'est super non la même
université où avait été Macron alors
j'ai développé ma vision du monde bon là
je pas peut-être me poser la même
question je développerai ma vision du
monde c'estàdire dire une France non
alignée et je recommande à tout le monde
d'être non aligné une France altterre
mondialiste une France des causes
communes et une France qui met sur la
table une offre de travail commun avec
des causes communes je te coupe une
France
nonalignée ça vaut quand on a un EDF
avec un parc nucléaire qui tient le choc
une France non alignée ça vaut quand on
a l'alarme nucléaire une France non
alignée c'est quand elle a une une
agriculture qui nourrit son peuple une
France non ligé c'est quand elle a des
universités qui rayonnent dans le monde
là à l'heure actuelle le système
énergétique français et
claudicamp je te vois auss les
sourcils les universités françaises sont
déclassé pas déclassé attends vous allez
l'agriculture française est sous
perfusion que ce soit de subvention pas
de subvention d'hydrocarbure pas
d'hydrocarbure de fertilisants qui
viennent pas de chez nous
et j'en passe donc pour être
nonaligné il faut être aussi souverain
chez soi il faut être aussi rayonnant là
à l'heure actuelle est-ce que la France
n'est pas l'ombre
d'elle-même bon d'abord je pars du point
numéro 1 et on va y
revenir le nonalignement à provocation
l'indépendance bon on va y revenir les
de la France bon clairement mais il y a
un responsable c'est le
néolibéralisme l'état non non c'est pas
bien l'état le Mamou machin ah vive le
marché l'entreprise libre en avant il y
a rien qui marche d'accord il y a plus
rien qui marche nous sommes maintenant
en
situation de ce qu'on aurait dit
autrefois de
tirmondisation on avait le meilleur
système de santé du monde il a moitié
par terre si c'est pas 3/4 on a on avait
le système énergétique parmi les plus
performants à une époque où on pensait
que c'était bien le nucléaire et cetera
je jette pas la pierre à ceux qui ont eu
cidé mais depuis il y a eu Dre Island il
y a eu Tchernobyl il y a eu Fukushima et
nous on est la France les amis la France
sur territoire tu vois un accident
nucléaire terminé un un
seul vous prenez le risque vous avez
décidé de continuer et non seulement de
continuer mais de fabriquer des
centrales don vous savez même pas elle
marche la preuve vous essayez d'en faire
une et elle marche pas celle qui a
flamois-ville d'accord alors stop les
bêtises on peut faire d'autrre chosees
l'agriculture elle dépend de subvention
commençons par dire une chose le fric
qui revient de dans l'agriculture
française qui vient d'Europe c'est le
nôtre d'accord ne commencez pas à dire
ah merci l'Europe nous a donné des sous
on donne des sous et l'Europe les
redonne et au passage il prend 9
milliards de plus pardon réparti oui
ouioui
non mais attends il faut voir le coup je
raconte ça à la tribune de l'Assemblée
nationale il y avait une dame qui était
là qui était ministre qui dit ah
Monsieur Mélenchon vous n'êtes pas
capable de comprendre ce qu'est la
solidarité je dis mais madame 1 fois oui
faisons de la solidarité mais comme vous
avez rien vous êtes pas solidaire enfin
vous commencez d'abord par reconstituer
votre propre capacité vous elle me
traite de tous les noms il me traitent
tous de nationaliste borné g g la dame
en question elle s'appelle l'oiseau elle
dirige la campagne des des macronistes
aux européennes la première chose
qu'elle dit elle dit c'est un scandale
on donne plus que ce qu'on reçoit ben
fallait écouter ce que je disais madame
et depuis qu'est-ce que vous avez changé
je vais vous dire rien si on paye plus
qu'avant puisque les Français comme nous
sommes la France alors nous payons à la
place des Allemands ce qui ne voulaient
pas payer leur part de ce qu'ils
auraient dû payer pour les Anglais enfin
bref je vais pas ici raconter l'histoire
interminable de la façon avec lesquelles
sont calculé la part de chacun on réussi
cette cet exploit d'avoir monsieur
Macron qui dit formidable l'Europe a
accepté de s'endetter au nom de toute
l'Europe oui formidable commentaire d'un
internaut chernoby la zone d'exclusion
c'est 2600 km² 1 % de la France c'est
une superbe réserve naturelle on peut le
voir comme ça mais je crains que
alors l'exemple de de
Tchernobyl est intéressant parce que tu
fais le tu prends un compat et tu vas
dans la vallée du rô je veux pas donner
des mauvaises idées d'accord mais c'est
au même endroit que tu as je ne sais
combien de réacteurs plus toute
l'industrie chimique
française imagine-toi un petit Fukushima
dans ce coin-là autre que comme il y a
un fleuve on est d'ailleurs dessus pour
prendre la flotte comme les têtes d'œuf
ont pas réaliser que le réchauffement
climatique fr cl l'au il y en a moins et
de Yau elle est chaude et qu'on
refroidit pas une centrale avec de l'eau
chaude donc de temps à haute on l'arrête
et de temps à haute on a des problèmes
mais tout le temps tout va direct dans
la mer Méditerranée ce qui a un des
problèmes avec l'Ukraine pendant ma
campagne présidentielle j'ai proposé les
casques bleus alors out qu'à l'époque
personne répondait rien à quoi que ce
soit de ce que je racontais monsieur
Macron lui téléphoné à Poutine donc il
avit pas le temps de répondre à
Mélenchon donc il na jamais répondu
attend pour prendre la défense de Macron
Poutine il a dit moi je veux pas avoir
quelqu'un en face de moi qui soit contre
mon plan ils sont d'accord les Russes et
les ukrainiens et les Ukrainiens ont
voter pour demander des casques bleus
autour de leur truc moi je me disais va
va expliquer un Russe qui vient
d'envahir monsieur on ne peut parler de
rien si vous n'avez pas retiré tout le
monde d'abord bah l'autre va dire bah
attends mon pote je'explique c'est la
guerre ici alors je retirerai quand
j'aurais gagné si tu prends le problème
par ce bout là tu arrêtes rien par
contre si tu viens et tu dis écoutez on
a un intérêt commun tous les causes
communes he vous les Russes vous les
ukrainiens et nous les français on a un
intérêt commun on veut pas se fout sur
on évite de se [__] sur la gueule mais
c'est même pas le sujet le sujet c'est
juste on a pas besoin que les centrales
sautent donc est-ce que vous êtes
d'accord oui oui dire les Russes parce
que tuas retrouver 3 ou 400000 types qui
sont prêts à mourir comme ils l'ont fait
pour isoler la centrale de ternobil tu
les as plus en Europe nulle part donc
faut arrêter de raconter des salades si
on a un problème on aura Fukushima
c'est-à-dire rien ni personne tu prends
les gens et tu leur dis allez vous
partez et ben va essayer de les faire
partir donc on a inêt à mettre des
casques bleus partout mais suppose que
tu viens tu dis écoutez voilà là il y a
la centrale de machin la centrale de
truc on va mettre des casques bleus ah
bon tu prends ton pas et tu commences à
dire bon bah c'est quoi la zone
d'exclusion d'accord alors combien de
kilomètres carrés autour ah ben les
casques bleus on les met 1 km demi
autour de chaque de allez deux de chaque
cent alors tuas une grosse bulle donc là
il y a plus de guerre là-bas il y a plus
de guerre là tu as pas mis de canon ça y
est tu es parti tu es dans la discussion
sur comment on arrête la guerre mais si
c'est seulement des grandes déclarations
tu arrives à rien c'est pas de la
diplomatie de faire ça c'est de la la
gesticulation la diplomatie c'est
comment j'attrape un problème par un
angle concret d'intérêt commun qui fait
que même des gens qui veulent centre
égorgé se disent bon là d'accord on peut
faire à cet endroit-là on fait une pause
mais mon pote tu fais une pause à cet
endroitlà tu l'as fait à côté on a gagné
je veux dire on peut faire avancer les
choses parce que si on y réfléchit bien
les Ukrainiens veulent que les Russes en
aille de là et les Russes sont quand
même conscients du fait que maintenant
qu'ils ont tout cassé suivant le méthode
de guerre habituelle euh
bon qu'est-ce qui se passe là-bas il y a
des discussions sur selon la méthode de
guerre de tout le monde d'ailleurs les
Américains ont tout cassé oui c'est vra
les Russes ont tout cassé vra mais eux
ils ont quand même ça y va quoi c'est
vraiment ils pètent tout les Américains
aussi mais si tu veux les américains ils
pètent pas toujours le bon endroit ils
bombardent depuis 10000 km les
Américains il commencent avec les avions
d'abord les Russ pas fait ça d'ailleurs
pourquoi les Russes ont pas envoyé les
avions de toute façon ils perdent toute
leur Gard
donc les gens prennent cher pour rien
parce qu'à la sortie l'Afghanistan n
même point qu'au début et ainsi de suite
mais revenant à le le concept cause
commune nonalignement quand tu es non
aligné bah les gens se disent pas
celui-là il vient pour me faire les
poches non aligné ça veut pas dire
neutre hein j'ai j'ai vu parce que
Macron c'est quand même un phénomène
dans son genre tout d'un coup il dit euh
nous sommes écidistant entre les Chinois
et les Américains ah pas du tout nous
sommes pas du tout écidistant de qui que
ce soit si ça dépend qui a raison et qui
a tort
si c'est les Américains quienvahissent
les Chinois et ben on sera pas
équidistant on dira vous foutez le camp
si c'est l'inverse on d bon non aligné
et ben on dira pareil on dira vous n'z
pas aller là comme j'ai fait moi alors
que je pensais que la Russie devait être
intégrée dans l'Europe qu'on devait tout
faire pour intégrer la Russie dans
l'Europe mais il y a plus malin que moi
vous avez vu ils ont réussi une manœuvre
formidable ils ont collé la Russie avec
les Chinois grandiose réussite hein
comme les américains se P entre eux sur
mais r ils ont quand même réussi un truc
extraordinaire ils ont agrandi l'ANT ah
bah oui alors non mais je veux dire en
matière de connerie il y a eu quelques
record de battu hein dans toute cette
période parce que c'est là qu'on voit
d'ailleurs le caractère absurde de cette
stratégie moi j'étais pas pour que
l'OTAN rentre en Ukraine mais alors si
le résult alors il y avait 1000 raisons
pour ne pas le faire mais ne pas
intervenir ne pas envahir alors ça
pardon pardon mais c'était quand même à
la portée de n'importe qui de comprendre
qu'à partir du moment où il passait la
frontière tous les voisins diraient oh
nous sommes tous menacés il y a pas
Besin d'être un AIG pour comprendre ça
et surtout que ça allait coller toute
l'Europe aux États-Unis d'Amérique c'est
un désastre diplomatique total ce qu'a
fait Poutine ça vaut pas un clou et et
et d'ailleurs et par consé un COPEC h
pas un COPEC ouais un COPEC on va dire
bon moi je sais que mes camarades et moi
on a accueilli des opposants à la guerre
c'est ça qui est le plus tu vois le plus
pourri dans la vie
politique c'est que tu as tous ceux qui
bavarde oui oui l'Ukraine machin qui
m'accuse d'être poutinien je pense les
vers c'est il battent tous les records
ceux on leur a dit mais écoutez c'est
très bien venez avec nous donnez votre
part pour payer le loyer des réfugiés
qu'on a là qui sont des réfugiés russes
socialistes c'est les insoumis qui
payent personne d'autre ils sont même
pas occupés de savoir où ils sont alors
c'est pour dire la le ça c'est pour
parler du concret mais je reviens à la
diplomatie aux stratégies diplomatique
il faut passer par du concret on est au
21e siècle tous les peuples savent lire
et écrire tout le monde regarde la télé
c'est pas la peine d'essayer d'enfumer
les gens donc mieux vaut partir de
choses simples concrètes que tout le
monde comprend là on va avoir des gros
problèmes à l'instant on vient d'évoquer
Poutine et la Russie il y avait beaucoup
de gens dont moi qui pensaient qu'il ne
fallait pas laisser la Russie filer et
que on avait intérêt à arrêter de leur
raconter des salades à arrêté de les
encercler parce qu'il s'en rendaient
parfaitement compte et qu'il fallait
prendre les choses par un autre bout bon
très bien on oublie c'est perdu on est
passé à autre chose mais là regardez ce
qu'on va avoir un problème qui va nous
arriver qui pour quelqu'un comme moi va
être un gros problème les briques tout
le monde sait ce que c'est le Brésil la
Russie l'Inde la Chine et l'Afrique du
Sud se sont re regroupés dynamisés Loula
est revenu au pouvoir donc on a plus
bolsonaro qui était un agent des
Américains et euh tu as des sources de
ça c'est gratuit non je veux dire il
faisait la politique des Américains on
va dire he bon c'est quand même une
petite différence oui oui c'est vrai
mais bon quand je dis un agent c'est au
sens économique du terme
euh politique hein du terme c'est pas le
seul d'ailleurs he parce que il y a des
personnes il y a des journaux les
Américains ont le bralon comme dirait
l'autre les Français aussi he dans leur
domaine on fait pareil et donc ces
gens-là
euh ils se remettent en mouvement et ils
disent écoutez on en a
marre de faire les échanges en dollars
parce que pourquoi on ferait des
échanges dans une monnaie qu'on contrôle
pas et qui a cette caractéristique c'est
que les États-Unis en sortent autant
qu'ils veulent al pourquoi remonte 15
août 1971 Richard Nixon dit maintenant
un dollar ça valit 25 je crois 25 de gr
d'or ça non c'était un rapport avec une
matière première les gens faut faire un
peu d'économie mais la monnaie remplace
le troc mais ça veut une une monnaie
reste toujours un équivalent entre deux
valeurs réelles sinon elle ne représente
rien trop maintenant quand même alors
eux ils disent ce jour-là en aû ils
disent écoutez vous ferez ce que vous
voulez mais nous on s'en fout maintenant
il y a plus d'or en échange de dollar
faut dire que les Français avaient abusé
aussi hein le général de Gaul avait
demandé à transformer tous ces dollars
en or c'estit pour casser les pieds
américains il demandé aussi de faire
rapatrier les réserves d'or françaises
en France et ben c'est la vie hein bon
euh donc les bricks donc alors les
bricks sont là et disent écoutez les
Américains vivent à crédit du reste du
monde parce que depuis le 15 août ils
appuient sur un bouton ils sortent les
dollars dont ils ont besoin et alors ils
avaient un un truc les Américains qui
étaient très auut point qui a fonctionné
longtemps c'est par exemple toi tu es
l'Arabie Saoudite alors vous êtes un
petit nombre et vous avez du pétrole
mais beaucoup de pétrole alors il y a le
Qatar l'Arabie Saoudite les Émirats
Bahrain tout ça bon chacun avec son son
tas d'or alors au début ouais mais son
tas d'or après parce qu'il avait ses
dollars et que je te construis un
immeuble et que je fais si que je fais
là parce que le problème numéro 1 du
capital c'est de se réinvestir ça sert à
rien de faire des tas de d'argent donc
commencé à dire je te protège alors
attends tu vas voir donc je t'achète tes
ton pétrole to tu en as pas besoin tu as
pas besoin de tout ça donc tu le vends
et moi je te le paye en
dollars toi une fois que tu as
misas tu as mis des diamants sur tes
mitraillettes mis des dents d'oré à tes
chameaux créer une autoroute bâti des
immeubles tu as encore des milliards on
se comprend envoie les milliards achète
des bondes du Trésor des États-Unis
d'Amérique ça tombe bien je m'en dette
je te payes tu m'achètes de la dette et
et à tous les deux toi tu en as pas
besoin moi j'en ai besoin là j'en ai
besoin toi tu en as pas besoin tu as pas
besoin des pétrole mais tu as besoin des
dollars tu as compris le coûp ça marche
les Saoudiens ils ont compris que les
Américains pouvaient répudier leur dett
c'était dans la Constitution alors
attends tu vas voir les Saoudiens ils
ont mis le temps qu'il fallait et puis
donc ce système a fonctionné avec les
saoudiens et avec les producteurs de
pétrole ensuite avec les Japonais qui
achetaient à tour de bras tout en
produisant pour le compte des États-Unis
et enfin Richard Nixon à l'idée du
siècle c'est d'aller voir
Mao la Chine était comment dire avait
fait toutes sortes d'expérimentations
qu'on va qualifier d'audacieuse hein
ouais ou des les TER pour la population
il cétait ruiné et donc ils mettent au
point un truc
d'échange et les Chinois se mettent à
être ce qu'on appelait l'atelier du
monde et en Europe tous les arrogants
moi je l'ai entendu le discours c'était
ouais ouais eux ils fabriquent les
ombrelles hein et nous on va fabriquer
les produits haute valeur ajoutée
d'accord donc maintenant ils produisent
en effet les ombales mais aussi les
produits haute valeur ajouté nous rien
comme ça on en est à pleurer sur des
tarmarques d'aéroport pour récupérer des
marques en tissu qu'on est même plus
foutu de faire bon on connaît cette
situation donc ça marche comme ça et les
Chinois se mettent à accumuler une masse
de dollars comme jamais ça s'était vu
dans l'histoire et puis un jour tout le
monde finit par les chinois c'est
d'abord des réalistes d'accord donc ils
sont devenus très puissants ils
fabriquent tout et ils commencent à dire
écoutez il y a un truc qui peut ils sont
devenus eux-mêmes un pays capitaliste
c'est le capitalisme en Chine d'accord
il y a une économie mixte il y a un
secteur étatique mais ils sont pris dans
les contradictions du capital
l'accumulation la baisse des salaires
l'impossibilité de diffuser et puis la
production de bulles énorme alors par
exemple vous avez une ville en Mongolie
je sais pas si ça sait dans les gens qui
nous écoutent j'ai oublié le nom de la
ville tu peux enlever ton morceau de
scotch qui te dérange là où tu le colles
il est moche hein ouais oua ouais non
mais ça fait un moment que j'essaie de
l'enlever pour quand même être plus beau
tu vois non mais t'inquiète on a dit que
c'était du scotch bon vas-y continue les
gens croi que j'ai fait couler que je
sais pas quoi de ma poche non tuas
357 al donc les Chinois ont ils ont une
situation qui est typique d'une économie
de cette nature c'està-dire d'une
économie capitaliste où le où il faut
que ça circule ils ont fait comme ont
fait tous les autres c'est-à-dire des
endroits où tu te mets à construire et à
et à faire à faire une dynamique est-ce
que vous vous rendez compte que l'année
2010 la moitié du ciment qui se
consommait dans le monde c'était en
Chine faut vous rendre compte de ce que
ça veut dire
alors ils ont fait par exemple une ville
entière où il y a personne euh parce
qu'on vend pas des fois ils abattent
eux-mêmes les immeubles qu'ils ont
construit ils ont des problèmes rudes et
en même temps ils sont ultra performants
ils ont posé un satellite sur la face
obscure de la lune ils ont une station
internationale dont on entend jamais
parler mais ils vont et ils reviennent
ils sont la pointe de la technique de
notre époque et aussi la pointe du
fonctionnement d'un capitalisme
extrêmement bien organisé mais qui ne
peut pas s'émanciper des crises qui sont
liées au capitalisme lui-même donc ces
gens ils ont des problèmes qui sont liés
à ça alors qu'est-ce qu'ils ont commencé
à faire à dire écoutez ça peut pas aller
qu'on échange et c'est eux qui ramasse
le plus dans une monnaie qu'on contrôle
pas progressivement ils ont mis au point
leur la diffusion mondiale des chaînes
de compensation et puis ils disent bah
écoutez maintenant le dollar c'est pas
une bonne idée donc nous vous proposons
une monnaie
commune à
l'ONU une monnaie commune c'est pas
possible monnaie commune ég fin du
dollar fin du dollar égale catastrophe
pour les États-Unis d'Amérique qui
produisent plus rien c'est quand même ça
il y en a qui ont essayé oui tu vas voir
attends les mecs ont pas lâché prise ah
personne veut de la monnaie conune très
bien arrive les bricks dilmoussef
ancienne présidente du Brésil de gauche
elle dit écoutez on vous fait une
remarque les pays qui sont dans les
bricks ils représentent plus du PIB
mondial que ce que vous avez dans le G7
tête des autres qui disent ah non non
c'est pas vrai ce petit calcul si c'est
vrai là-dessus il y a presque 20 pays
qui veulent entrer dans le système des
briques et ils n'en prennent que six
dedans tu as l'Arabie Saoudite tout d'un
coup miracle l'Arabie Saoudite dit oui
bah pendant qu'on y est ça serait le
moment de dire que nous on peut
envisager d'échanger notre pétrole en
monnaie nationale et plus en dollars
alors là alerte générale alors
réfléchissons ça c'est la situation
qu'on a ils sont réunis cet été ils sont
revenus à la charge avec l'affaire de la
monnaie commune mais ils ont pris une
décision d'orénavant ils échangent entre
eux en monnaie nationale ah 42 % du PIB
mondial va s'échanger en monnaie
nationale et plus en dollar la crise est
garantie d'avance pour les États-Unis
d'Amérique le jour où tu pas avec des
dollars qui représenteront quelque chose
de produit aux États-Unis tu es pas sûr
d'avoir la valeur du papier sur lequel
il est écrit nous croyons en Dieu et
c'est un dollar qui est marqué dessus
d'accord donc ça c'est un des plus grand
facteur de déstabilisation du monde
c'est la dédolarisation alors des gens
comme moi qui jusque là on dit en AR
ralbol de l'impérialisme américain on
peut pas on a quand même moi je suis pas
pour le chaos donc on a un gros problème
nous ne pouvons pas accepter que comment
dire sans rien faire des gens décident
de [__] par terre tout l'équilibre sur
lequel fonctionne le monde donc on a
intérêt et vraiment intérêt à ce que le
dialogue avec les Chinois avec les
Brésiliens il soit pas sur la base de
l'arrogance et qu'on écoute ce qu'ils
disent comment pourrait-on passer du
système dollar universel à une monnaie
commune de référence commune dans des
conditions telles que tout le monde
s'effondre pas j'ouvre une parenthèse
les chinois ils sont pas si gentils que
ça il ils ont
exporté au détriment de leur population
des choses pour rendre dépendant les
occidentaux pour faire venir les
industries occidentales chez eux ils ont
pratiqué ça c'est guerre économique là
ils pratiquent l'espionnage l'espionnage
économique ils ont un système de valeur
très spécial Al on est en train d'y
venir le le Crédit Social le flicage par
caméra l'intelligence artificielle oui
tout ce qu'on est en train de faire en
France c'est ça donc ils sont pas si
gentils que ça les chinois mais attends
personne ne dit qu'il y a des gentils et
des Méch dans la politique
internationale d'accord tout le monde
est en compétition donc tout le monde
est méchant le problème c'est comment on
trouve un point d'équilibre qui fait que
on évite de s'écraser les uns les autres
donc moi je ne dis pas c'est pas trop
tard ça ah bah si c'est ça je pour me
pendre mais le PROE de l'action
politique c'est que tu crois toujours
que tu peux arranger les choses quand tu
es dans ton vélo que tu as descendu ta
pente de ta montagne et que tu commences
à vouloir freiner que tu vois que tes
freins il chauffent et que ça freine
plus ouais qu'est-ce que tu fais tu mets
les pieds mets les genou en général ça
non mais en général tu mets les pieds
puis après tu vois ça m'est arrivé un
compte de fois parce que je suis pas
très malin du temps où j'en faisais he
avec les dents non mais bons faut pas
non plus donc la situation à l'heure
actuelle on rentre dans une pénurie
énergétique non mais attends tu voulais
dire quoi que les Chinois tu avais des
démarrés sur ils sont pas gentils bon ok
mais bon tu connais un gentil vas-y
raconte-le moi raconte-moi les
États-Unis d'Amérique c'est les gentils
c'est les Français ils espionnent tout
le monde espionnent tout le monde
regarde les États-Unis d'Amérique ils
ont espionneré la France le président
français Hollande cette carpette il a
même pas c'est gratuit c'est non non non
non non moi je je je alors je vais
t'expliquer pourquoi c'est une carpette
un autre peut-être un autre mot non bon
si tu veux ce trop gentil non c'est
faible c'est faible les États-Unis
d'Amérique espionnent le président
français il y a une réunion qui a lieu
juste l'été suivant des gens disent on
peut pas aller à une réunion pareille
tant qu'ils ont pas présenté d'excuses
et qu'est-ce qui se passe rien on y a
été on a fermé notre grande bouche et on
se fait espionner ils ont espionné
Bruxelles tout le monde espionne tout le
monde les Français espionnent il y a un
réseau mondial d'espionnage américain et
il y en a un français avec des stations
de télécommunication dans le monde
entier hein et moi je félicite ceux qui
font marcher tout ça parce que nous
avons besoin de bons renseignements et
quand on a des renseignements mieux vaut
les utiliser parce que pour l'instant
c'est pas merveilleux comment on a
réussi à se av voir passer trois pouch
dans un pays comme le Mali où on avait
5000 militaires et on l'a pas vu en seul
se préparer peut-être qu'on aurait pu
être comment dire moins naïf et en
particulier ce que nous on aurait dû
faire les Français c'était pas de
s'indigner que des militaires maliens
veuillent faire ceci ou cela parce que
le pays est à eux au maliens mais nous
les français on y va on fait quelque
chose on vote une fois au Parlement et
ensuite terminer pendant 9 ans plus de
débat un type tout seul décide si on
envoie du matériel si on en envoie pas
si on envoie des soldats 54 personnes on
a perdu je vais te donner un autre
exemple tu vas voir les gentils les
Américains décident un jour tout seul
que én avant oui il y a un traité très
intéressant sur l'espace qui dit que
l'espace est un bien commun que c'est à
toute l'humanité que ça n'appartient à
personne les Américains disent oui oui
on est d'accord ça n'appartient à
personne sauf à celui qui arrive le
premier alors tout le monde dit allz
fort quand même ça revient à dire quoi
ça bah oui ça veut dire que si on trouve
c'est pour nous c'est pas pour vous ah
bon et c'est pas tout attends tu vas
voir la suite et puis alors ils disent
vous êtes d'accord bon bah on est
d'accord oui on n'est pas d'accord les
Américains font le tour vous êtes
d'accord signer vous êtes d'accord
signer ça tombe bien tu as pas de fusé
signe et ainsi de suite ok ça s'est
passé comme ça une fois qu'ils ont eu
tout ça ils disent et alors écoutez non
faut être sérieux hein bon supposons que
je trouve quelque chose et que c'est à
moi sur la planète il faut pas qu'il y
ait de malentendu donc il faut qu'on ait
le droit de sécuriser l'endroit où on a
trouvé tu vois comment s'est dit
sécuriser ça veut dire que 1 premier
arrivé premier service c'est la
colonisation qui recommence 2
j'arrive je peux installer une base
militaire pour taper celui qui viendrait
dire à propos il y en a un bout qui est
à moi moi je serai le responsable
français un bou moi il y en a un qui a
eu un culot comme ça pas possible c'est
quand les Espagnols et les Portugais se
sont partagés les Amériques c'est
François
prier tu sais ce qu'il a dit le gars il
dit il dit moi je voudrais voir le
testament
d'Adam qui dit que les Amériques c'est
pour vous deux et pas pour nous français
tel quel c'est là le mot de François
1ier bon donc nous on est en droit de
dire attendez premier arrivé premier
servi en plus il met des bases
normalement qu'est-ce que tu fais tu
protestes làdessus tu as le Luxembourg
ils sont toujours là dans les bons coup
ceuxl ils arrivent ils disent nous aussi
on reconnaît ça et d'ailleurs si vous
voulez installer votre société
d'exploitation d'un astéroïde vous
pouvez l'installer au Luxembourg donc le
Luxembourg grande puissance
spatiale autorise l'implantation sur son
territoire ce qu'il prévoit la suite
mais nous les français qu'est-ce qu'on
fait qu'est-ce qu'on fait 1 on n' parle
pas au Parlement on a des fusé on a des
droits comme tout le reste de l'humanité
à avoir un avis sur le sujet qu'est-ce
qu'on fait rien et on envoie un type qui
est responsable dans des organismes
français de l'espace pour signer un
accord dont personne n'a jamais entendu
parler naturellement vous jamais il
s'appelle Artémis les Français ont signé
que un premier arrivé premier servi de
on a le droit d'installer des bases pour
sécuriser une zone nous les français
nous avons accepté que on mette un point
final à la démilitarisation de l'espace
et nous avons nous les Français accepté
que l'espace ne soit plus un bien commun
sans en parler une seule seconde un type
tout seul a décidé ça dans un bureau le
président de la République et il a
demandé à un autre d'aller signer à sa
place parce que lui-même sans doute il
devit avoir trop honte d'aller signer un
truc pareil donc on est reparti comme en
14 la même
chose ça veut dire que l'espace va être
un lieu de peut être un lieu
d'affrontement terrible c'est pour ça
que quand je te dis écoutez on pourrait
s'entendre nous autres là hein on va
voir les Marocains on va voir les les
les Sénégalais on va voir tous ceux
d'Afrique avec qui on parle la même
langue on dit on pourrait se mettre
d'accord tous ensemble pour faire
quelque chose notamment par rapport à
l'espace parce que par exemple les
Marocains ils font fabriquer des
satellites parce que par exemple
l'Afrique du Sud qui n'est pas
spécialement lié à la France hein mais
qui n'a pas la même langue que nous et
bien eux aussi sont présents dans
l'espace le Niger vous savez pas où
c'est B regarde sur une carte parce
qu'il y aura un milliard d'habitants
là-dedans d'accord donc tous les autres
francophones autour il faut qu'il
commence à se poser des questions vous
allez être entouré d'anglophones qui
vont arriver avant vous sur les endroits
indispensables donc on pourrait
peut-être s'entendre vous voyez que je
vous ai parlé tout à l'heure
d'université de l'espace il y en a
quelquesuns parmi vous qui sont dit il
est sympa mélanchonon mais est-ce que
vous comprenez que je suis en train de
vous parler de comment faire en sorte
que on ne soit pas rayé de la carte
parce que comme on est en train d'agir
là on va se faire rayer de la carte tout
ça parce qu'on se croit très important
et qu'on n pas capable de prendre le bon
pli du bon côté c'est-à-dire en
respectant les gens ça coûte que ça de
respecter il y a des centaines de gens
intelligents pourquoi on les empêche de
venir étudier en France pourquoi nous on
va pas là-bas pourquoi on est dans cette
relation de fou d'arrogance et vous êtes
tous là à dire oui les immigréci les
immigré là est-ce que vous êtes au
courant que si vous les avez pas vous
pouvez pas vivre est-ce que vous avez
compris ça est-ce que vous êtes prêt à
payer à leur place 30 milliards d'impôts
qui payent sur la consommation sur les
cotisations sociales où on va avec tant
de bêtises d'aveuglement de mépris pour
les
autres mais bon ça vaut la peine le
réchauffement climatique ça me rappelle
un co de 2008 je crois bien à l'école de
guerre anciennement collège interarmé de
défense qui était les les implications
du réchauffement climatique sur le Livre
blanc de la défense frç ouais aller
trouver les DVD et
donc on se retrouve à l'heure actuelle
avec un réchauffement climatique qui qui
bouleverse tout un tas de zones
habitables la température le taux
d'humidité ça tue les gens quand ça
monte on va se retrouver avec beaucoup
de gens qui vont migrer et des pays qui
vont être
déstabilisés là on se rend compte qu'il
y a des populations de l'Afrique noire
de pays qui sont d'as d'Asie de gens qui
sont migrants économiques qui sont
créolisés avec la culture du téléphone
portable à regarder les influenceuses
qui roulent en battion et que tout se
passe bien que c'est facile la vie ou ce
ils on les leur aussi hein de quoi les
Bugatti veyon d'influenceuse oui aussi
bien entendu mais elle roule pas en
Bugatti
veryon ou d'une autre marque d'ailleurs
donc ils sont aussi créolisés dans le
bon sens ou dans le mauvais sens ù ils
sont occidentalisés par la toute au même
mode de vie c'est ça que vous êtes en
train de décrire jeis d'accord d'accord
et donc il y a beaucoup de gens qui
bougent et Lampedusa 6500 personnes qui
arrivve le même jour des zodiaques des
tout ça il y a des gens en Europe qui
commencent à s'inquiéter ah bah il faut
dire que on fait ce qu'il faut pour
qu'il s'inquiète parce que quand tu vois
Lampedusa on te dit il y en a 10000 bon
très bien pourquoi personne n'ont
parlera bah si il y en a 10000 parce que
une grosse partie vient de lib où tout
on a tout cassé et où il y a bon
d'accord ils sont là 10000 très bien
alors vous prenez votre calculette et
vous diviser 10000 par 28 États de
l'Union européenne et ça vous donne 250
pingouins à accueillir chacun ça va quoi
hein vous avez accueilli
4800000 Ukrainiens sans pousser un
soupir 120000 dans ce pays en France
c'est-à-dire l'équivalent d'une année
entière
de migration j'ouvre une parenthèse les
Suédois qui av une politique migratoire
très accueillante là disent ou là ça
commence à pas aller là
ah oui non mais partout partout alors
nous là évidemment comme on est européo
centré qu'on pense qu'il y a que nous
qui intéressons le monde on regarde pas
la vérité 80 % des mouvements de
populations se font dans le sud
c'est-à-dire des gens qui passent les
frontières et qui désorganisent tout à
mesure qu'ils avancent donc tu as deux
solutions ou bien tu crois que tu vas
empêcher ce phénomène donc tu te
demandes comment tu fais après tout
pourquoi pas moi j'ai dit vaut mieux que
les gens rent chez
eux quand tu as du développement tu peux
rester chez toi mais il y a des
situations où ça ne sera pas le cas tout
simplement parce que chez soi n'est plus
habitable n'est plus habitable donc les
gens se mettent en mouvement tu n'y peux
rien donc soit tu fais face alors là
pour l'instant ce qu'on a nous ce qui
nous arrive en Europe c'est rien c'est
Epsilon par rapport à la masse des gens
qui se déplacent on parle de 250
millions de gens qui vont se mettre à se
déplacer à mon avis ça sera plus
important ça c'est la phase visible des
choses celle qui énerve tout le monde pu
alors tu peux y aller tous les jours
hein les immigrés ceci les immigrés cela
et cetera tu pourrais poser le problème
autrement de dire bon je sais pas on va
être 7 millions bon à 100 millions en
France on peut faire plein de choses
hein bon uctur qui vont avec bah tu les
crées c te blague créer des
infrastructures en essayant d'y
raisonner de les faire pas comme avant
c'est-à-dire en imperméabilisant tout
mais c'est du boulot comment on a fait
après guerre en reconstruit comment on a
fait quand un million de pieds noirs
sont arrivés en France et ben on s'est
mis à construire à faire à refaire les
routes et cetera donc quand tu as du
monde le monde n'est pas une charge
c'est l'inverse plus tu as de monde plus
tuas de gens qui font des choses qui
font du commerce qui échangent jeanluc
quand tu étais jeune oui il y a pas si
longtemps que ça
quand même c'était un autre monde il y
avait 2 milliards et demi d'habitants
sur la terre on disait que l'Afrique ça
s'appelait le continent vide
c'est-à-dire que il y avait personne et
très peu de monde bon maintenant
imagine-toi qu'un pays comme l'Inde pour
que tu arrives à faire le même nombre de
gens tu prends toute l'Afrique toute
l'Europe et la Russie d'accord c'est ça
l'ordre du monde aujourd'hui la Russie
sont pas beaucoup mais peut-être bien
enfin il y en a quand même 110 millions
ou 120 quoi 150 ça doit être ça j'ai un
peu perdu le le compte parce que un
moment donné ça s'est contracté d'une
manière abominable mais donc c'est je
vais attends je termine je veux terminer
sur une idée parce que sinon ça sert à
rien que je vienne pour redire des
choses que j'ai pu dire mais ce qui m'a
frappé un soir j'écoute le journal de
France 2 c'est le service public c'est
la voix de son maître donc il raconte ce
qu'on leur a dit de dire et euh
vilain non non non non non je donne mon
avis j'en suis libre et je dis c'est la
voix de son maître voilà il servent le
maître ou le capital l'un ou l'autre
mais le peuple jamais bon je je dis ce
que je pense voilà ça ne plaît pas aux
gens qui m'écoutent ils ont le droit toi
ils ont le droit mais je ne me taai pas
pour que ça soit sympa voilà alors j'en
viens là le gars je crois que c'est de
la hase qui dit il par un truc bon 45°gr
aux États-Unis oh là là catastrophe
alors c'est là-bas qu'il y a le record
des climatosceptiques les mecs ils sont
servis 45° sauf que à 47°grés tu peux
plus vivre et à 50 tu es cuit donc tu
peux choisir d'être un Américain cuit ou
bien tu t'en vas et d'ailleurs de laous
dit on se demande si dans 10 ans la
ville de phénix va encore être habitable
non mais attends il a raison de poser la
question c'est bien qu'il le dise bon là
c'est pas la voix de son m c'est c'est
quelqu'un qui réfléchit qui parle à
haute voix bon et il a raison mais toi
tu toi tu réfléchis en face et tu dis on
en est là on est au journal de 20h et on
est en train de dire gens on n'est pas
sûr que cette ville que vous voyez là
sur la carte elle sera encore habitable
dans 10 ans mais maintenant pose-toi la
question combien il y a de monde 1
million les Américains vont déplacer 1
million de personnes pour les emmener
dans un coin où il fait plus frais quand
est-ce qu'ils font ça où ils ont eu une
tempête qui leurait tombé dessus en
Louisiane 10 ans après il y a plus rien
de régler c'est la pagaille c'est le
désordre pourquoi parce que c'est une
société libérale il y a pas d'état qui
vient intervenir pour venir à la res
cous il y a pas de et alors là on a
appris tellement de choses dans le
bouquin de servig justement raconte ça
les types se sont dit dans
l'administration central si jamais on
contrôle pas ce qui se passe là-dedans
ça va être les meurtres les pillages et
les viols donc on envoie l'armée
résultat les seuls problèmes qu'il a eu
c'est avec l'armé parce que pourquoi
parce que les gens sidaient ils
s'entraidaient ils se pillaient pas ils
s'incendiaent pas ils s'entraidaient
l'entraide a été la plus forte tout à
l'heure la question m'a été posée on me
dit comment on va faire j'ai dit c'est
les circonstances qui vont nous pousser
vous de choisir ça sera une affaire
idéologi concrète chacun d'entre vous
devra se demander chacun pour soi ou
tous ensemble c'est de la philosophie
c'est de la morale mais c'est de la
politique concrète donc les années qui
viennent vous allez pas seulement voir
des gens qui viennent d'Afrique d'Asie
que vous savez pas où c'est que vous
trouvez ça très exotique et que vous
voulez pas les voir vous allez commencer
à avoir des Napolitains parce qu'on peut
pas habiter Naple à 50°gr vous allez
commencer à avoir des gens du monde
entier qui vont à l'intérieur des pays
se déplacer 75 % du territoire de
l'Espagne pourrait se transformer en
désert est-ce que vous comprenez qu'il
faut changer de méthode vous appelez ça
comme vous voulez mais si vous changez
pas la suite est certaine c'est ça qui
va vous arriver et ça viendra pas un
jour en vous disant début de la
catastrophe non ça va être par morceau
si vous êtes en train de le vivre
l'effondrement quand votre service
public d'hôpital marche plus c'est que
il est plus et s'il y est plus pour
l'hôpital il y sera plus non plus pour
l'incendie et ainsi de suite tout ce que
vous désorganisez sera désorganisé pour
affronter la crise et moi j'ai pointé du
doigt dans mon bouquin je dis attention
regardez ce qui s'est passé très vite
vous autres les plus jeunes vous avez le
nez dessus vous le voyez plus je vous ai
parlé du monde où il y avait 2 milliards
d'habitants maintenant on est 8
milliards depuis novembre dernier 8
milliards vous serait 10 milliards
comment vous faites croisez les doigts
pour que ça si si ça double deux fois
moi je serai la seule génération qu'
aura vu deux doublements vous avez
intérêt qu' en ai pas une autre parce ça
veut dire qu'on passerait de 8 à 16 et
de 16 à 32 bonjour tout le monde à 32
milliards d'habitants si vous voulez
vivre comme vous voulez là deuxème
élément je vous ai raconté tout à
l'heure le coup des poissons j'ai dit
vous en manger plus d'élevage que
d'avoir été cherché dans la mer ben je
vais vous dire aussi une autre chose qui
est nouvelle en 2008 pour la première
fois il y a plus d'habitant en ville
qu'à la campagne ça veut dire que
quelque chose comme 3900 millénaires he
non pas millénaire en tout cas 390000
ans pardon d'histoire humaine c'est la
campagne et encore si tu comptes pas les
hominidés avant bon c'était la campagne
et la ville c'était rien c'était 20 % en
1951 qu'on commence tous les
emmerdements à commencer par ma
naissance et bien vous aviez le 20 % de
la population mondiale vivait en ville
ok nous on était on était c'était déjà
plus concentré à cause de de de la façon
dont nos sociétés s'était développé dans
le cadre du capitalisme maintenant c'est
plus de la moitié vous avez compris ça
veut dire que vous avez maintenant une
majorité de l'humanité qui ne peut pas
vivre sans accéder au réseau du
collectif le réseau collectif devient
c'est les veines de l'humanité tu
enlèves le réseau tu peux plus vivre ni
vous ni moi on est capable de vivre en
élevant notre jardin sur notre balcon ce
n'est pas possible il y a une
génération d'accord tu avais les
toilettes au fond du jardin hein mais
bon tu avais ton potager tu avais ton
Mach je dis pas que c'était l'idéal je
dis juste que tu pouvais le faire
aujourd'hui tu ne peux plus c'est clair
tu ne peux plus donc tu es obligé de
faire face à cette nouvelle condition
humaine et de trouver une solution et
d'arrêter de faire des phrases comme
celle que j'entends comme je vois Macron
qui me prend l'idée il me prend l'idée
la planification écologique le gars il a
rien compris il en déduit que c'est de
la gestion prévisionnelle comme une
entreprise et c'est quoi sa
planification écologique tu as vu
l'exemple qu'il a donné on va faire des
piles au lithium tu vas le trouver où
lithium bonhomme où il est ton lithium
tu as rien compris tu recommences tu vas
faire des batteries à nouveau avec des
matériaux RARs et cetera tu vas faire de
l'électricité et tu vas vouloir la
stocker et tu vas la vouloir la faire
avec des centrales nucléaires alors
qu'on te dit sur tous les tons que tu as
une énergie gratuite qui est là qui est
celle des mouvements de la
mer elle est pas si gratite que ça non
j'ai raison tu peux y aller j'ai étudié
mon dossier c'est plus facile de faire
ça que de faire de l'
croyez-moi enfin bon en attendant pour
pas transformer notre rencontre en une
discussion sur les avantag tech la-
terer donc quand tu étais jeune
ouais vous étiez moins pas le sida
c'était un peu de bitnique vous aviez
vous aviez des ressources énergétiques à
porter de main il y avait encore les
colonies il y avait ah non non non quand
même quand j'étais jeune il y en avait
plus de col non c'était fini donc le pét
TR il y en avait encore beaucoup
facilement accessible facilement
exploitable là ta génération
elle nous laisse un monde en r c'est
clair c'est clair quand les jeunes se
vengeront de quoi tu me déterer pour
disperser mes eau non bien sûr que cette
génération là laisse alors d'abord je
veux dire un truc faut pas non plus tu
veux te faire incinérer
euh pourquoi pas je vaisir dire J a pas
pensé je je encore il reste en moi de
l'adolescent tu vois je continue à
croire que je suis immortel des jours
bon bref mais pour revenir à il faut pas
non plus raconter d'histoire hein le
monde dans lequel
euh moi j'ai vécu c'était un monde dans
lequel il y avait des guerres on sortait
d'une guerre abominable la guerre
mondiale ensuite il y avait des guerres
il y avait une dose de misère
équivalente ou supérieure à celle
d'aujourd'hui il y avait la colonisation
qui avait pas était un bienfait
contrairement à ce que certains
racontent euh il y avait une société
très tendue il y avait des inégalités
alors comme tout homme si tu veux
n'importe quel homme ou n'importe quelle
femme qui pense à sa jeunesse dire ah
c'est formidable en fait c'est ta
jeunesse que tu regrettes c'est pas le
monde qui était il était tendu il était
violent on s'y insérait il y avait une
difficulté mais là où là où là où oui tu
as raison c'est que on était sûr que
demain ça serait mieux voilà on se
battait on voulait faire le socialisme
ça doit être mieux pour tout le monde
d'autres dis disait ouais bah ça sera
peut-être pas mieux pour tout le monde
mais ça va être mieux pour moi ma
famille mon machin c'est vrai que
c'était un monde d'optimisme hein de moi
ce que j'essaie de faire c'est un
désastre se profilant comment nous on
réagit d'une manière positive
c'està-dire on doit le le le choix ça
doit pas être on continue comme avant il
a Vienne que pourra on verra bien hein
ou bien alors cri et lamentation
pleuricherie et gémissement on sait pas
quoi faire on a peur bon il faut trouver
un chemin humain et un chemin humain
c'est toujours un chemin qui te fait
dire bon pour moi c'est Cu mais pour mon
gosse non tu te projettes sur les autres
tu te projettes sur la jeune génération
alors moi je me dis à ma place à moi bon
je suis comme tout le monde j'ai une
famille enfant petits enfants donc
évidemment je pense à eux mais j'ai j'ai
été toute ma vie un homme de combat
engagé dans un combat collectif donc je
me dis qu'est-ce que je peux faire bon
bah voilà alors j'ai là je viens de
faire un livre qui concentre beaucoup de
choses et qui donne des clés alors c'est
le moment et je vous signale c'est pas
moi qui abuse c'est lui qui m'a fait
signe mais j'en profite pour faire de la
puu je vous signale que CRE est
actuellement en tête des ventes combien
c'est vendu ça al ça c'est vendu 20
balles c'est cher et et tu récupères
combien dessus ou tu donnes sais pas je
dois pas dire tous mes secrets mais je
non seulement un avaloir he non j'ai pas
eu d'avaloir tu as un
pourcentage il part où le poignon euh je
sais pas encore sans doute qu'il va
aller je pense ça va aller à l'Institut
Lab ici que j'ai créé bon si tu veux ça
va moi je vis j'ai besoin de rien puis
tu as vu mon âge j'ai pas de bagnole je
m'en fous il pas de chevaux j'ai vu je
dis ça pourquoi j'ai pas de chevaux
parce que il y a un truc qui circule
depuis 10 ans sur l'Internet qui raconte
ma fortune tu vois alors j'ai des
chevaux j'ai des bagnoles je ne conduis
pas voulez que j'en fasse combien de
femmes he tu as combien de femmes dis
donc tu me dis il était à combien de
chevaux et non mais ça rien à voir
attends tu te rends compte de ce que tu
viens dire vous avez entendu là ce qu'il
a dit bon non alors je parce que les
milliardaires ils ont souvent beaucoup
de attends moi sur ma feuille d'accord
ça me coûte he il a marqué célibataire
je paye les impôts d'un célibataire
d'accord donc s'il vous plaît mon état
civil c'est le suivant pour les impôts
et dans la vie célibataire après ce que
je fais de ma vie bah je fais ce que je
veux prof myque c'est ton profil sur
mythique célibataire je sais pas ce que
c'est sur quoi tu dis un mythique un
site de rencontre qu'est-ce que c'est ah
d'accord tu es pour le th asie ou tu es
pas pour l'euutthanasie quand tu seras
en yupala est-ce que tu préférais qu'on
te balance de la de la falaise ou tu
préférais crever dans un
épad c'est un peu dur de parler comme ça
il faut faut penser aux gens que ça
concerne moi je peux je ne peux parler
que pour moi il y a deux domaines où
l'expérience ne se partage pas jamais
entre être humain l'amour et la mort
d'accord c'est les deux moments où tu
sais pas tu peux raconter ce que tu veux
à ton fils ou à ta fille de toute façon
il n'importe quoi parce que il y a un
principe il y en a plusieurs qui sont à
l'œuvre mais il y en a un le plus fou de
tous les principes qui met la vie des
êtres humains en mouvement c'est le
désir le désir est aveugle je sais pas
pourquoi il va d'un côté ou de l'autre
que ce soit et ce désir il se il est bon
on le connaît on connaît le désir sexuel
ça c'est ce qu' a de plus le contact le
plus immédiat avec
euh quelque chose de tellement fort mais
après tu as d'autres forme du désir qui
s'empare de toi le désir de comprendre
de savoir de et tu es là bon tu as pour
rien comprendre qui te fait expliquer
trois fois le truc pour quand même
arriver à comprendre bon donc c'est une
grande
puissance créatrice féconde c'est
l'explosion mais tu racontes ce que tu
veux chacun mène sa vie et ses amours
j'ose même pas dire d'après ces règles
parce que je sais même pas s'il y a des
règles et puis la mort c'est pareil
alors ça fait un moment que ça dure hein
qu'on en discute
on est tous pareil on n'arrive pas à
concevoir l'idée qu'on ne soit plus
d'abord parce que dans notre programme
c'est visser dedans euh tu feras tout
pour pour survivre bon voilà c'est comme
ça c'est un principe autoorganisateur
numéro 1 je ne dois pas mourir numéro 2
qu'il faut choisir entre moi et mon
gosse c'est moi qui Meur numéro 3 et
ainsi j'en sais rien j'invente des
règles comme ça c'est pour la
science-fiction en quelque sorte donc
moi je ne peux répondre que pour
moi-même figure-toi que l'autre jour je
sais pas pourquoi je suis à une émission
un petit jeune homme qui m'interroge il
s'appelle benjamin du Hamel et alors à
la fin ils font parler euh Jupé je sais
pas pourquoi ils lui disent qu'est-ce
qu'il pense de sa mort et le gars il
commence à dire j'ai peur de la
déchéance enfin des trucs qui sont
émouvants et respectables on en est tous
là euh comme disait brê hein mourir
d'accord mais vieillir non bon d'accord
on en est tous là c'est la chanson de
brê alors euh il me dit et vous la
morti que tu me demandes ça à moi parce
que j'ai 72 ans mon gars mais tu es pas
au courant tout le monde meurt une fois
le Président miterran il est met pas
qu'on l'appelle le vieux moi ça me
dérange pas du tout on m'appelle aussi
le vieux et nous on l'appelait le vieux
parce qu'on avait été trop triste dans
notre jeunesse et lon TR qui on
l'appelait le vieux tu t'imagines le
truc cette histoire à tiroir donc le
vieux c'était le vieux maintenant c'est
moi le vieux je vois dans les
commentaires tu sais sur le les
commentaires sur les réseaux sociaux il
marqu ah le vieux bon ceci le vieux 25
chevaux c'est ça non non mais bon je
parle pas des cons qui racontent ça mais
je parle des gens sympas qui se marquent
qui se un peu de bois bon le vieux et
François mit vous savez on est toujours
le vieux de quelqu'un bon avisment il
était pas content puis dit on finit tous
pareil il fait comme ça avec la main tu
vois et puis il dit et on ne sait pas à
quel âge ça c'est pour moi
alors à mon tour de dire he vous savez
on est toujours le vieux de quelqu'un et
on finit tous pareil et il y avait alors
je lu raconte mon la mort quoi la mort
moi je suis stoïen donc la mort ça me
concerne pas quand je serai mort bah je
serai plus là pour en parler et avant de
l'être je serai vivant donc de quoi on
parle d'un truc qui existe pas pour moi
réfléchi attention à ce que je suis en
train de dire là bon existe pas pour moi
mais pour vous
oui alors j'ai pas fini ma phrase je dis
donc
moi quand j'estimera que c'est plus
supportable comme un stoïen c'est moi
qui é lumière bon donc tu es pour
l'ethanasie ta propre euthanasie le
suicide assisté oui il faut pas entourer
les moi j'aime pas le mot euthanasie il
fait peur le suicide assisté appelons
les choses comme elles sont le suicide
assisté oui je suis un stoïcien je suis
un Romain je me coupe les veines quand
j'estime que bon je sais pas si j'auris
le courage de le faire mais en tout cas
dans mon esprit je ferai ça un copain
qui a médecin il m'a dit tu peux
toujours parler c'est un truc de mec qui
se porte bien parce que quand tu es mal
par dessus tout tu veux vivre alors même
que tu es très abîmé je ne sais pas je
ne l'ai pas vécu je fais une réponse
abstraite mais la vraie réponse que
j'aurais voulu faire et que j'ai pas
fait juste pour l'embêter puisquil me
parlait de ma mort tu sis quand même pas
poli toi quitter toi tu as 40 ans de
moins que moi et tu viens me parler de
ma mort on pourrait parler de la tienne
pour voir pour mettre de l'ambiance sur
le plateau donc qui pour me parler comme
ça un peu de respect là je pourrais être
ton grand-père bon bref tu vois le le le
genre chacun il fait comme il est fait
moi voilà je suis comme ça je me dis
quand même mais la vraie réponse je lui
dis je la ferai pas tu vois ma manière
de te montrer que c'est pas bien ce que
tu viens de faire je te fais pas la
vraie réponse qu'il faut faire
écoutez-moi bien la seule mort qu'on a à
craindre la seule c'est celle des
autres la mort c'est une affaire de
vivant c'est ce que tu as plus
là c'est
parti et c'est fini pour
toujours des gens qui sont ton frère ta
sœur tu sais même des fois c'est même
pas ta famille tu vois c'est pas ta
famille ta famille c'est douloureux
pourquoi c'est douloureux parce que on
s'est fabriqué ensemble dans une famille
alors en bien en mal he je suis pas non
plus en train d'idéaliser mais les
humains ce qui compte c'est tout ce qui
se déchire tout ce qui est brisé et
surtout ce qui est
irremédiable alors c'est une discussion
curieuse là que tuas engagé figure-toi
que cet été je vois un documentaire
c'est un type c'est un amerlot qui a
trouvé une grotte dans laquelle il y a
des hinidé alors ils ont trouvé des os
des os et encore des os jamais trouvé
autant ils en ont plus trouvé à propos
de cette hominidé comomo sapience
d'accord c'est une belle série je crois
que je l'ai vu sur Netflix ou sur Hart
je me rappelle plus qu c'est sur Hart
hein non sur har peut-être c'est
peut-être sur har ou peut-être sur Apple
TV non non non sur haré ou Netflix alors
en tout cas bon c'est haré haré et alors
le gars bon il est là il peut pas
descendre dans le trou parce qu'il faut
passer dans un boyau 18 m de fond puis
le mec il est un peu confortable donc il
passe pas dans le trou donc c'est les
autres qui passent et notamment des
femmes parce qu'elles sont plus menu et
elles sont là-bas au fond du trou avec
bon en train de fouiller avec le pinceau
tout ça ils mettent la lumière il
ramassent les os et tout puis au bout
d'un moment lui il est en haut il
regarde merde qu'est-ce qui se passe il
y a un rond autour du squelette merde
c'est une tombe c'est pas juste des os
et il se trouve que c'est pas un homo
sapiens c'est pas un homo sapiens c'est
une créature qui a un cerveau qui est 30
% plus plus petit que le nôtre d'accord
et ils ont une tombe et s'il y a une
tombe ça veut dire qu'il y a un au-delà
dans leur conviction il y avait un
au-delà alors peut-être que la croyance
dans l'au-delà a à voir avec l'émergence
de la conscience quel que soit le niveau
de la conscience viendrait la
sensibilité la conscience de soi et puis
tu sauras jamais ce qu'un éléphant pense
de sa mort tu sauras jamais ce qu'un
singe pense de sa mort mais il y a une
chose qui est sûre c'est qu'il comprend
la mort de l'autre il comprend la mort
de son maître il comprend la mort d'un
autre animal comparable si tu lui
montres un un miroir il voit qui s'est
fait une tâche sur le
front la conscience de soi amène la
conscience de sa limite et tu n'en as
conscience que par celle des autres donc
tu as besoin absolument des autres pour
savoir que tu es toi méditeer j'ouvre
une parenthèse il est là tu as V l'heure
qu'il est ça fait 2h qu'on parle tu
envie de faire pipi ou quoi 2h 34 4
minutes combien 2h34 tu parlais tu
paralais que la mort c'est un truc de
vivant que tu pleurais ton frère que
c'était irrimédiable est-ce que tu
inclus le chat le chien l'âne l'animal
de la famille ça fait partie de la
famille
évidemment pas de la même manière il
faut dire les choses pour une raison qui
tient sansout leil le deil est le même
la la souffrance est comparable la
souffrance pourquoi parce que avec un
être humain ton intrication va être très
très puissante mais il y a des gens qui
ont un lien aux animaux qui est
extrêmement profond peut-être des fois
plus profond qu'avec d'autres humains et
par conséquent il est absolument certain
que pour ces humainsl la
souffrance doit être comparable à celle
de la perte d'un ami d'un frère dans
quand je dis dans moi quand je dis d'un
frère c'est parce qu'évidemment j'ai
dans l'esprit la mort d'un un des miens
de mes plus proches qui était Bernard
Pignerol qui me manque et d'autres avant
lui François de la pierre qui est mort
et d'autres copains
bon tu sais une vie de militant les
militants sont ta famille autant que
ceux à qui tu es comme on dit lié par le
sang tu drôle d'idée tu lié par le sang
quel sang bon bref tu es lié donc les
animaux d'abord sont doués de
sensibilité et ils te manifestent leur
sensibilité les animaux sensibles se
socialisent tous sans exception à leur
manière qui des fois a un déchiffre par
les humains on pas le temps qui voit pas
qui regarde pas alors bon l'affec d'un
singe tout le monde le voit l'affec d'un
chien aussi et ainsi de suite et puis en
a d'autres non on le voit pas et
pourtant il est certain que il doit
exister est-ce queil y a un sujet que tu
souhaiterais aborder avec
nous tout ce que vous voulez mais il
faut bien que ça s'arrête à un moment
non le sujet c'est Aton des
raisons je voudrais dire l'importance de
vouloir importance de choisir d'être
optimiste l'importance de la vertu la
vertu comme j'ai défini tout à l'heure
tu vois c'est ce qui est bon pour tout
c'est bon pour moi ça vaut la peine
et le le le le monde contient de la
beauté
et se mettre en harmonie avec lui c'est
juste essayer de faire un truc comme
danser tu vois je pas danser moi je
savais pas danser un jour je me lève
j'invite une femme à danser j'ai suis
dansé tout comme ça j'avais regardé les
autres je pas comment ça m'était rentrer
je sais danser et bien quand tu danses
tout d'un
coup comment tu vas appeler ça ça
s'appelle l'harmonie c'està-dire
qu'est-ce qui se passe ton rythme
devient celui de ton partenaire de danse
et plus le les figures vont être
mouvantes et et que ça va se faire dans
rythme plus tu vasê être envahi de du
sentiment du
rythme sa beauté va t'envahir tu vas
être de mieux en mieux tu vois si tu
sais valser les pieds à plat c'est un
expoir moi je valser là sur la pointe
bon mais tu peux faire d'autres trucs
par exemple je sais pas quoi moi une
danse à deux he toujours je parle pas de
la danse tout seul tu vas faire un beau
tango ou tu vas faire un
beau bon quelque chose comme ça plus tu
vas entrer dans la danse plus le
sentiment de l'harmonie va t'envahir et
te donner une sorte de de jouissance par
soi-même assi-toi au bord de l'eau
regarde la mer il se passe rien si il se
passe la mer
moutonne tu vois la
flotte la mer
scintille le mouvement
de non moi je l'entends pas il me fait
il me fait signe comme ça mais il est
sourd comme moi donc la merre moi
j'entends la vague quand elle arrive tu
vois pou pou pouf pchouf mais il y a des
gens ils entendent ils entendent de loin
la mer bouger mais moi je la vois
scintiller je la vois bouger et bien tu
sauras une chose si tu regardes la mer
assez longtemps tu te guérit le cœur
juste parce que ta tête va te mettre en
harmonie avec ce ce mouvement qui
parcourt l'eau un conseil l'harmonie
c'est un objectif dans la vie
exceptionnellement on va demander un
conseil pour les vieilles générations et
un conseil pour les jeunes
génération je connais pas les vieilles
générations moi je peux rien dire sur le
sujet montre-moi le livre et regarde un
conseil pour la la ma génération
trouvez-vous un bon
coiffeur voilà moi j'en ai un dans ma
rue il est
turc la vérité c'est que je comprends
rien à ce qu'il me dit et lui il
comprend rien à ce que je lui dis mais
on s'entend très bien non je blague mais
c'est pour dire la vie est faite de
rencontres tu sais comme ça incroyable
là quand j'ai fait la photo je vous
raconte ça pour vous faire marrer il
m'avait tellement bien assaisonné qu'on
a dû attendre 8 jours que ça repousse un
peu pour que je puisse faire la photo
donc conseil trouver un bon coiffeur tu
fais 10 ans de moins sur la couverture
on n pas photoshopé jurer je veux pas je
suis bien dans ma peau j'ai pas envie
d'avoir 20 ans tu vois un conseil pour
les jeunes générations et oublie pas je
veux trois bouquins entre les deux et
mais la quoi donne-moi trois livres à
lire et un conseil pour les jeunes
générations attends conseil pour les
jeunes générations qui je suis pour
donner des conseils aux autres moi j'en
sais rien j'ai fait ce que j'ai pu j'ai
tatonné je vous conseille de faire
pareil avancez-vous avancez-vous
avancez-vous avancez-vous faites euh
changer le monde ne ne il faut avoir des
ambitions à la hauteur du besoin
d'accord faut avoir des rêves c'est pas
je vais donner un exemple les gars qui
jouent au loto alors si tu gagnais 1
million pourquoi un million sil s'agit
de rêver de gagner au loto je veux dire
10 milliards si tu veux à tout prix donc
mettez vos rêves alors en plus gagner
trop d'argent est immoral mais si vous
voulez avoir des rêves voyez en grand
vous voulez un monde propre tu veux tu
veux retrouver Paris où il y a des
moineaux il y en a
plus bon tu voudrais qu'il y ait des
papillons dans les champs il y en a plus
si chez moi parce que comme j'y suis
jamais les papillons me disent on est
peinard
là rêver en grand et maintenant
malheureux vos rêves c'était des choses
que nous on avait comme ça mais on
savait pas que c'était important on
savait pas que avoir des papillons dans
son champ c'était vachement important
c'est maintenant seulement trop tard et
là il y en a plus bon ça c'est le truc
aimez la vie ça vaut le coup ayez des
grands grands grands grands grands
grands rêves abattez la citadelle du
capitalisme ce système est maudit il
passera l'histoire l'humanité a changé
je sais pas combien de fois de mode de
production finissez-en avec ce truc
alors après des livres alors là non là
c'est le début de la fin pour
moi TR J je sais pas combien j' j'en ai
aimé qui ont changé ma vie il y en a un
que bon un quand même tarif
minimum Michel Tournier Vendredi ou les
lmes du Pacifique version intégrale pas
la version pour les plus jeunes ça
oui ça c'est bien ça c'est un beau livre
qui va vous apprendre plein de choses
sur la vie surtout les garçons les
garçons parlent jamais de choses il y a
une culture viriliste peut-être que
maintenant c'est plus comme ça mais
quand moi j'étais jeune homme il y avait
une culture viriliste qui rabottait la
réalité tu vois on t'interdisait presque
d'avoir des sentiments de pleurer
d'avoir de la sensibilité ça se faisait
pas voilà bon ça c'est un livre après
bon qu'est-ce que vous pourriez lire qui
vous soit utile en politique à part mes
propres
livres il faut quand même que je
recommande
un moi ma ma mon moment de contact avec
le marxisme c'était à travers un bouquin
qui a un titre affreux L'Idéologie
allemande mais ça m'a ça m'a bouleversé
après moi je peux pas al trois trois je
vais j'arrive au bout d'accord mais j'en
aime des milliers mes pauvres c'est mais
livre c'est c'est des personnes tu te
rends pas compte toi c'est des je vis
avecun de science-fiction ah de
science-fiction deux attends
science-fiction bon ah il faut alors je
vais te dire
euh
pour
l'écriture le berceau du chat court
veneur
goutte c'est trop tu te marres trop
c'est trop bien écrit et j'ai utilisé
des techniques d'écriture de ce bouquin
le berceau du chat cour deergoutte tu
pourras regarder abattoir numéro 5 aussi
c'est bien après il faut lire un peu
d'Asimov sinon c'est pas sérieux lit le
cycle fondation après le à mon avis
auteur immense de la fiction
délirante c'est Philippe cadiic tout le
monde a vu bled Runner je suppose dans
ceux qui qui m'écoutent et quand vous
regardez bled Runner vous touchez du
doigt à quoi sert la
science-fiction pas à anticiper un peu
un peu mais surtout la science-fiction
c'est une allégorie ça raconte la vie
différemment dans bled Runner tu as des
robots qui veulent savoir quand ils vont
mourir de quoi on a parlé un instant
c'est une allégorie mais l'histoire elle
est bien faite donc tu suis l'histoire
des robots qui veulent savoir alors ils
font C ils font ça pour le savoir ils
vont retrouver le gars qui lesac crréé
tout ça mais oh oh oh c'est juste une
allégorie vous êtes pareil vous courez
partout pour essayer de savoir qu'est-ce
qui va vous arriver demain pas de bol
vous ne saurez pas Jean-Luc Mélenchon
merci ah tu vois faut bien que ça
s'arrête à un moment ou un autre
[Musique]
hein